e e
good
morning uh welcome to all of our guests
to uh House Education policy and
administration we have several hearings
this morning um a couple of uh
housekeeping items um for the uh
committee um there is now coffee and
coffee cups in the office in 205 for us
um thank you several people including
Kristen uh for bringing in the cups very
important um and for anyone who has a
notebook and wants three hole punch
there's one in the 207 office for
you
um we have several people who will be a
little bit late this morning but um we
can get started because we see uh Prime
sponsor um representative Harvey bolia U
here today ready to uh introduce uh her
house bill 71 which is prohibiting the
use of facilities of a public elementary
school public secondary school or an
institution of higher education to
provide shelter for aliens who have not
been admitted into the United States so
representative
welcome turn on my micone um thank you
very much good morning my name is uh
representative Juliet Harvey bullia
represent Sulton and samton in bellnap
County um and I am introducing House
Bill 7
which as uh chair cordelli pointed out
uh says that it's prohibiting the use of
facilities um although I would argue
that this bill does not prohibit or ban
anything um I think that's uh probably
some something that could have been
worded a little bit better and I'll
explain why um but just to say that this
um bill is modeled after the schools not
shelters act introduced by Senator Cruz
in uh 2023 cille
2983 um and the origin of this bill and
the reason was that in 2024 Brooklyn uh
New York students were forced into
remote learning uh for a couple days
while they their school was turned into
an emergency shelter for a certain group
of people um and I've given you some
handouts there copies of uh I think the
first one is parents fume after students
at James Madison High School forced to
learn remotely while schooled in a uh
schooled housing housed Asylum
Seekers um so what what I have a problem
with that is um especially on the heels
of the covid shutdown that we weathered
here in New Hampshire where schools were
shut down for almost a year um my school
in
winnisquam uh the students were forced
into remote remote learning for nearly a
year and my personal experience of that
is that you know I had a school a child
in high school at the time and um you
know he was looking a little depressed
after a while being uh cut off from his
friends and his his school environment
um and I called the school counselor and
I said what can we do here you
know it's it's not going well and she
said well come to mention it
I've getting a lot of calls about that
from parents and parents are calling and
complaining that their children are also
depressed are not thriving so um I think
uh enough has been said about how much
students and parents and Society in
general suffered enough during the uh
shutdown uh during our covid crisis and
when it happened again in New York um it
was yeah it was amazing to me that it
would come back and haunt us again in
this way and another shutdown um and
naturally parents were fuming over it
it's unnecessary it's disruptive it's it
was just it's the wrong way parents had
no idea how long this was really going
to go on was it you know um obviously it
was supposed to be uh temporary and it
was but was it temporary because there
was so much outcry
um get so this this is a this is of this
is where this is the origin of the bill
um there's another article in here from
boston.com
um bringing it back to our Boston area
New Hampshire area uh readers agree with
Governor hey's ban on migrant sleeping
at Logan Airport and this is another
reason I brought forth the bill was
because we heard about these uh families
and um how Logan Airport was turned into
a shelter I mean uh it's shocking that
it went on for so long all summer um and
people weren't happy about it as you can
see from the newspaper article it's
inappropriate it's not really doing a
service for anyone not the people uh
using the airport and and and also not
for the uh people who are in the shelter
it's rather indignant I think there are
better ways and people need to do
planning um governments need to do plan
before they bring in these big
populations um so as I said uh this is
this bill so this the wording for this
bill I took almost word for word from
the schools not shelters act um I'm
going to go over a few other things here
and then we'll go into what the bill
does and does not do I also gave you in
your packet some um some other just
stats um I've highlighted on this page
is really fine print page the um Refugee
po population resettlement country by
origin from like the last 10 years and
I've highlighted the top three countries
of origin for last year as you can see
it it changes if you look at the chart
it will change the country of origin um
year-over-year uh we had some record
numbers in uh
20 23 was uh one of the highest
years um and then it tapered
off um and and I'm just giving the
committee some of this background
information so they can kind of see
what's going on in New Hampshire
particularly how things work uh it seems
sort
of it's information that doesn't get out
there so um and then you have a letter
fiscal year 2024 Refugee Support
Services formula allocations in a few go
to the second page I've highlighted New
Hampshire and um with the amounts and
also you'll see the proportion of
population arrived or served and that
this is purely just background
information I don't it's not necessarily
directly impacting bill um and it also
shows you um
[Music]
now so it's just some some background
information but um so to the bill itself
um is a very simple Bill there are a
number of things it does and does not do
it does allow for short-term Emergency
Shelters by the general
population
um it only applies to aliens as defined
by the US government which is not a US
citizen or National a
non-citizen it this bill does apply to
refugees people who have um achieved
Refugee
status it does not ban schools from
housing non-student populations so I
don't know why they use the word
prohibited because um so according to
this bill the
um one of the it sets a condition on
receipt of the money that you take from
the state
um you agree to this condition that you
will not house this specific population
and turn your schools your functioning
schools into shelters for the specified
aliens and there is a carve out for um
short-term uh emergency
um uh housing not to exceed 72 hours so
there are some Provisions for emergency
s Sheltering and also if you need to
turn your school into shelter for an
extented period of time because of some
uh weather event if it's open to the
entire Community then it's it's it's
fine this bill does not stop stop
schools from doing that um but what this
bill does is prevent schools um you
know uh insisting that uh schools um
turn their um it does not it does
prevent remote learning
and this is what uh the main focus of
the bill
is um and one last note about the fiscal
note at the end
um you will see there this bill does not
create positions does not require
funding of any kind um but they did put
a methodology at the end that is um
unusual I think it uh in worst case
scenario the department estimates this
lot large loss of millions of dollars
now I checked with um former
commissioner John Stevens from the DHHS
about this he said that that in his
opinion was erroneous the way it's
worded that it should have said that the
the amount is
undeterminable um and instead of saying
you know that it may um so there is no
uh way to prove or disprove there's no U
reason to believe that any kind of
policy is going going to impact our uh
receiving of these federal
funds and I'd be happy to take some
questions if the committee CH thank you
uh questions from the
committee yes represent
food thank you thank you for taking my
question would this bill include a
school district building that was
currently vacant and not being used for
educational purposes but still owned by
the school
district thank you for your question
representative kuger that's a great
question in my uh estimation I don't
think so because it is not technically a
school and they it's not functioning as
a school it's simply a building owned by
a school Sim similar to um any other
property that a school might have a
field or something like that I guess
that's just another
item but it's not functioning as such
thank you thank you
for the questions yes representative
Sally thank you and thank you for taking
my question I'm thinking about the
situation A couple of years ago where uh
the state of Texas without notifying the
state of Massachusetts put I think it
was 200 people on a plane and sent them
to Martha's Vineyard so that they
arrived in the middle of a snowstorm
with no notice and no opportunity for
the state to plan in any way shape or
form for these people they did not know
were coming um and certainly couldn't
leave on the streets in the middle of a
snowstorm um and so you're part of your
premise is that people need to plan in
advance I'm curious when um other states
act in ways like that how do you
anticipate other states would be able to
plan if there is no notification and if
there is no process for
that thank you for your question
representative um it's not my position
to figure out where these groups will go
only to say that we shouldn't displace
one vulnerable population for another
vulnerable population our students being
a vulnerable
population and and and and risk their um
you know their well-being uh for another
group it other Solutions will have to be
made I I'm not at Liberty to uh design
the programs in that way but there are
other places there are schools that are
closed down too so
representa Cornell Thank you thank you
for taking my question have you heard
about this happening in New Hampshire or
possibly happening in New Hampshire
or thank you for the question a great
question representative Cornell um no I
have not that's a good question and a
fair question and I have not um heard of
it happening I guess my hesitate my
focus on the bill was because we're so
close to Boston and Massachusetts and it
was happening to different degrees
there um that it sort of uh sent alarm
you know raised alarm bells for
me in this page that you gave us it's
highlighted are those numbers that came
to New
Hampshire the this one here yeah um yes
that is the this is strictly New
Hampshire at the top I know it's small
letters but says new Hamp New Hampshire
o r r eligible population resentment
that's the office of refugee
resettlement and I got this information
off of um I think some of it it came
from
DHHS uh they have a a page about it and
they they run this program um so we do
have this program although it's you know
sometimes people aren't understanding
exactly where they are who these
populations are Etc but so that's why I
kind of brought in some information just
just for background so that
um people can take a look at it follow
up Mr chair one more yes yep so I I
think these are the numbers that come we
have New Hampshire is an
immigration Reception Center where there
are places that are set up to receive
them so we are set up to receive that
and I think those groups know ahead of
time exactly how many people are coming
and where so these numbers are are
already provided for and I think they
already have schools houses
clothing everything already set up for
them so this isn't a group that would
arrive in New Hampshire I I I I I think
you agree with that that it's not a
surprise that here they are and would
have to put them in a school these are
numbers that are planned for correct and
and my um thank you for the followup
that I'm just providing it simply as
background so in theory these
populations are provided for so I'm not
claiming that they're going to all of a
sudden disrupt the systems um only that
each school system is is kind of
different um and that there would be no
harm in putting this section of uh House
Bill 71 no no harm and putting it in our
statute because it doesn't really if
there's no harm done if if they um if it
just sits there and nobody has any plans
to turn our schools into shelters but if
if for some reason say Massachusetts had
a giant influx of immigrants or other
parts of New England
and um it's a possibility that it could
happen in sometime in the
future
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question one of the questions
that I have is that in addition to the
fiscal note that you um that you read
before us um noting the 12 to18 million
per year are there any other uh programs
with respect to the immigration
resettlement act um such as uh human
trafficking Assistance asy programs
refugees and humanitarian paroi programs
that could be at risk if something like
this were to go into
effect I mean in my opinion I I can't
even imagine how this would put any kind
of program in Risk I have we heard of
any um Federal do we know of any um
times when the the federal government
has denied us funding because of
uh a remote uh you know just a obscure
piece of uh Statute in here that is
probably never going to be used I mean
do they do they deny us
funds there's no there's no basis for
that I couldn't find it I I tried to
look I called uh DHHS the commissioner
there there's no they have no know of it
ever happening or they said is you know
they put that in there just um it's very
Loosely worded like very liberally
worded and um they don't have any
evidence that the that no hard evidence
that they can supply that claim you know
that points to the fact that they we
would be denied any kind of funding for
any programs follow up uh thank you Mr
here um and and to that end I I guess
would there be any other uh undue
burdens to political subdivisions law
enforcement other other things as a
result that you may not be aware of that
funding could be at risk as a
result I can't imagine um I I can't I
did some research I couldn't find any
reason why this this would uh encumber
anything um in fact they schools can
um can just ignore this their state
funding if they wish and and and do as
they please and turn shelters
I mean excuse me turn schools into
shelters as they wish uh this this bill
does not uh prohibit them from doing so
they can do it all on their own if they
they really want to this this doesn't
stop any school from doing that it only
ties the money if you receive the state
money then you this is one of the
conditions that's all so it doesn't
prohibit
it yes representative Bon uh thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um there was a previous
question that mentioned um uh would this
apply to other buildings that the
schools or school districts currently
don't use but my question is what would
it apply when schools are not in session
say when schools are on breaks vacation
breaks or summer over the
summer um good question representative
um I I I would I would guess that it
does mean that that if if longer than 72
hours and it only it was only for alien
populations and they came in and said we
want to turn um we'd like to turn a
certain school for the summer and it's
going to become a um Refugee housing I
think I think this bill would prohibit
that um in this
way represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for coming before us um
so given the testimony that you uh you
you've uh said right now we haven't had
an incident of this happening in New
Hampshire um so would you consider this
bill to be more proactive instead of
reactive thank you representative
Freeman um yes I I mean I I consider it
yeah proactive yeah well it's it doesn't
really harm anything by being in statute
but it will give parents assurances and
PE of mind that this isn't going to
happen in New Hampshire so you know if
for instance the school was turned into
emergency
shelter
um for for one day or whatever that's a
short term less than 72 hours they can
say well they have to be out of there
you know within a certain time frame I
think what happened in New York was you
know they started to you know we had Co
and and the lockdowns and everything and
we got back to normal and then boom you
know we had you know in Brooklyn no
we're going to turn your schools into
something else and you're back to remote
learning and I think it just it was the
the last draw for parents um and uh
that's why they were so Furious and
understandably so because of the the
idea that we don't know how long it's
going to go on for you know um so at
least this puts some time frame around
it and some guard rails around all these
you know turning building municipal
buildings into other
things thank
you yes representative Hall thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh you referenced the
methodology on the uh the worst case
scenario from the doe and the person you
checked with said it was it shouldn't
have been 12 to 18 million it should be
undeterminable so you I guess the
question is
was he saying it could be a loss of
Revenue but just not sure how much was
that the problem he saw that shouldn't
have said 12 to 18
million thank you representative Hall um
that's a good
question without knowing too much and
without like putting words into
commissioner Steven's mouth um I think
what how it I understood it
was they have no idea of knowing they're
simply saying there's some money there's
some funds this is a an
association uh at the at best this is
how I find it I tried to look and see if
there was ever a case where States lost
money um due to policies like State
policies I can't find anything I don't
see how they'd even know that we have
this law to be honest with you so um we
could pass this law that nobody would
know I mean what are they going to do
say oh we're not you can't partic speak
I mean so when I was looking around when
you go to apply for this um Refugee
resettlement program through your state
each state has to come up with a plan so
they you know you're going to receive
some refugees and the the plan I
couldn't find a copy of the plan but
each state government has a a plan and
they have to you know say things where
they're going to put them they have to
have a plan or they should have a plan
plan in place that's part of um the
agreement there's nothing that I found
that
says that you can't pass certain laws I
just couldn't find it it's just not in
there so I think it's really um
I I I I don't see any evidence for
saying that there's any reason
why the uh 12 to 18 million isn't in any
sort of
Jeopardy or even that it you know if you
look on our Refugee support Services
formula allocation it's not even close
to that amount it's like a million so I
don't know where they even got that
number I know that there's some HUD
funding in there too but
um I don't see how that that would
impact it at all a followup so
commissioner Ste Stevens didn't say that
there definitely wouldn't be a loss of
federal revenue correct he just we
didn't speak in absolutes like that
absolute uh representative Hall I
don't I mean
we didn't discuss it in that terms I
didn't try to to Pig you know to pigeon
hole it in that respect I was just
trying to understand where what the the
methodology
was and yeah okay thank
you thank you um I'm both intrigued and
concerned by the
verbiage in the methodology particularly
the second sentence where I see words
such as
suggests May
potentially since we're having this
discussion about the loss of federal
revenue in your conversations with Folks
at
DHHS were you either offered or did you
request the substance uh of the of the
concern uh the basis of the concern that
resulted in words such as suggest May
and potentially and if not would you
would you
suggest that it might be helpful for us
to drill done on this and ask for why
and what what what's the language here
that results in this opinion from
DHHS yes thank you representative Terry
I am very concerned
about how the word may Etc in here and
the implication that there is a a real
threat or or anything um there's nothing
that I got from when I was speaking with
d Jess that that no no uh implication
that that the commissioner was concerned
at all
um that it was any kind of real threat
so I think I mean when I looked at the
Senate bill um the companion Senate bill
for this there wasn't any sort of
methodology similar methodology where
tying it there was nothing like that so
uh when I looked at that there's a bill
in um I think it's Tennessee the same
bill there's no sort of methodology at
the end saying that this is a threat to
anything so I I just um this is very
concerning to me yes I think the the I
want to see evidence you know follow up
so so just to button this
up there there's no statute and there's
no policy that was cited and provided to
you for this
opinion correct thank you representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman good
morning I see it
um pardon pardon my you may have already
said this I missed it because I was I
don't have the bill actually I've been
trying to find one um but no let fine I
it wasn't over but that's okay that's
not the point my question is would this
bill is
past preclude or prevent school systems
and buildings being used in the
summer would this bill prevent school
systems from being used sum yes to be
used for housing well for housing yeah
under the bill okay under the bill isn't
that what um representative Cornell was
asking was that similar what is that the
same question or similar so is is that
sort of like yes or no I mean I'm an old
guy um that's thank you that's that's um
so I would say yes I would say that if a
school decided to it doesn't really say
I mean that the point of the bill is not
to put uh children into a short-term
learning scenario now I representative
Woodcock I I think just about every
school has got something going on in the
summer the summer programs and and
whatnot if they're
displacing summer program summer school
and in um camps and whatnot then yes I
would say that it it would uh prevent
that so possibly Mr chair yes follow
follow up yes thank you just for clarity
so the answer I just want to be clear so
the answer is under this bill if it was
passed the intent of the bill is not to
allow any of those facility to be used
even when they're uh absent of students
say in the summer there's no programs
going
on if this if schools were turned into
Refugee shelters in the summer
displacing
student um school programs yes I think
that would be a violation of this but
it's not displacing it's just empty for
the summer well it's not empty because
the school is never empty in the summer
I mean they have they have all kinds of
things going on in the summer okay thank
you yes representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking another
question the word rep Refugee has come
up numerous times um representative do
you know the difference between a
refugee and an asylum
Seeker um thank you um I as best I can
tell representative
Freeman uh an asylum Seeker is seeking
Refugee status and a refugee has uh been
awarded if you will a refugee status in
the United States after applying after
court cases legal cases Etc is that your
understanding may I follow up yes so
technically you're saying that refugees
have been vetted by the United States
immigrations and Customs Service correct
is my understanding that they are vetted
yes thank
you I listened to a Boston radio station
um quite often and seems to me I've
heard stories about uh problems in the
uh migrant shelters um in the Boston
area are you aware of any
difficulties um in the shelters in
Massachusetts um thank you
representative cordelli um Mr chair I I
have to admit I do not know how that is
but we do um we have had a number of um
unfortunate criminal cases crimes being
committed by uh Refugee Seekers or just
um people who had not received Refugee
status in the Boston area I think um not
I don't have that information but
there's been a number of news articles
and then
unfortunately up in Vermont um a border
patrol agent was just killed a couple
days ago um by a u somebody who had
violated their visa um overstay their
visa and was fleeing up um I
think from this is my understanding was
fleeing up uh through Canada uh was St
stopped by a border patrol agent and
unfortunately shot and killed them so
it's um there is crime and it is a real
thing um I have visited uh the border
patrol up in Vermont our Swanton sector
and um it's a serious business um we
don't know who these people are and
that's part of this other issue is that
um you have unknown populations and and
people running away from crimes in other
countries uh here and we just don't know
it's chaos questions representative s
thank you Mr Speaker just for a point of
clarification about the definition of an
asylum Seeker because that came up a
moment ago um an asylum Seeker
specifically is a person who left their
country and is seeking protection from
prosecution and serious human rights
violations um in that other country but
has not yet been legally recognized as a
refugee and is waiting to receive a
decision on their Asylum claim just to
be clear about what that definition
actually is
okay thank you very much uh
representative thank you committee
members um next uh Jerry FW
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Jerry FW and
represent the New Hampshire Association
of school
administrators thank you for the
opportunity to speak uh to you this
morning um several questions came to
mind and I would like to offer uh from a
practitioner standpoint having been a
superintendent uh in a community that
dealt with uh schools as Emergency
Shelters um just to share some of the
thought thoughts and questions that came
to mind as I read uh this particular
piece of
legislation with
um line six emergency shelter at housing
provided exclusively to specified aliens
the question that came to mind is who
determines on
site whether entry should be granted to
a community member or not is that the
school principle
is it the administrative assistant is it
the
superintendent in kir we had seven towns
do we have seven Town
clerks sitting in the lobby of the
school determining whether a person
could be admitted to the emergency
shelter or not because of their status
as uh a resident or immigrant or
not um one of the other issues that that
uh arose as a question uh with 7 toour
limitation we did have an instance and
those of you who have been around for a
while may recall some major ice storms
and when I was at karge we actually had
to extend uh for over a week the
opportunity for our citizens to stay in
our schools because they didn't have
power in their own homes and so our
schools some of our schools um Nanda and
the Middle School uh had emergency
shelter status uh so that folks could
come have hot meals have showers sleep
there I remember the national guide
moving cots into the gymnasium at the
New London elementary school so the
folks could stay as long as they needed
to uh but we didn't have someone at the
at the schoolhouse door if you will
checking uh status uh the same with the
Middle School seven towns serving seven
towns um so those were uh a couple of
the questions that came up in terms of
um the practical application if you will
of this legislation at at the local
level a couple of other things came to
mind during uh Representatives testimony
um one question is does this apply to
public charter schools because um as you
learned in your orientation session the
other day presented by uh attorney
Fenton from the doe unless it says
Public Charter Schools they're not
included uh in any legislation so that's
one of the questions we have Charter
Schools all over the state does this
apply to public charter schools could um
uh in terms of serving as
shelters um and uh the representative
spoke about remote learning and the
fears of uh schools uh displacing
students uh for long periods of time and
subjecting them to remote learning I'd
like to remind this committee that
remote learning isn't a thing in this
state any longer we cannot put our kids
out for remote learning for any extended
periods of time that's a rule that we
have to adhere to so the the point that
that schools would close send their kids
home and put them on remote learning for
extended period of times can't happen in
New Hampshire can't speak to other
states that do it but it cannot happen
in this state so uh those are the points
that I wanted to raise I'm happy to
address any questions from members of
the committee and thank you for the
opportunity question from the committee
representative woodcock thank you Mr
chairman yeah good morning sir good to
see you again good morning U just a
quick question to followup um I'm still
having trouble with the this bill in
terms of the my understanding of the
facility is it your opinion if this bill
was passed that a school building
facility could not be used if empty
during the
summer there's nothing that addresses
the summer so it would have to be the
assumption that it would apply at any
time of the year thank you thank you Mr
chair forther questions yes
representative Morris it's to my
understanding that wouldn't it be easy
to verify the status through like a
driver's license or a passport for
someone seeking let's say natural
disaster happens and you can verify
who's legal and who's not than thank you
for the question representative moris uh
I guess my question as a practitioner
whose job is that is that the School
principal's job is that uh the
custodian's job because the custodians
there at 8:00 at night when somebody
shows up or is that a town official job
who
responsibility that's not spelled out
here and I think in terms of of applying
a law that those types of details need
to be addressed uh so there's no no
Hocus Pocus at the at the you know at
the point of need we don't want to put
anybody in a bad position including the
person that's trying to seek
legitimately
shelter thank you for the
question any further questions see none
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman um no for the cards right
else who wish to testify on House Bill
71 seeing none we'll close the hearing
and uh start the next bill in about 20
minutes thank
you
e
e e
we're going to get going on the next
hearing um on House Bill 440 relative to
educator licensing and I recognize
representative cordelli to introduce the
bill uh thank you very much uh Cher
Noble um for the record uh Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro
wolfboro and oopy in the beautiful Lakes
Region and uh this is House Bill
440 uh it's related to
education educator or licensing and U
was it last week um maybe yes I lost
track of time a little bit but um we
heard from uh uh Diana Fenton from the
Department of Education about uh Ru
making and the need to be specific in
terms of what we want to make rules
regarding when we put in
legislation and this um legislation is
the result of working with the
department and I believe there is a
represent attend representative here um
that can provide technical assistance um
in relation to this but um this uh amend
this U legislation uh specifies the
rules that should be required related to
licensing and also very importantly uh
specifies that um CTE teachers can be
exempt uh from um some of these uh tests
uh especially if they have uh an
industry recognized credential we've
talked about in the past
um because we want U uh experienced uh
trades and teaching um in the CT centers
so that's an important um uh piece of
this uh bill I
believe
um and there are uh tests that can be
required um I know uh working on
literacy there are uh tests required um
for uh uh uh licensing and and sometimes
for
renewals um but I think that this uh
meets the desire to have
specificity with regard to Ru making
with regard to uh educator
licensing thank
you thank you any
questions representative Woodcock thank
you madam chairman um represent a quick
question um on the professional
education assessments page eight I mean
line eight in the back
um is this is this are they going to be
stipulated
by um licensure or certificate are it
going to be stipulated somewhere it's
just part of the question the followup
is if it's a renewal and I've taken the
initial test on the one certification uh
test do I need when I renew my license
do I need to take the say they change
test assessments um I think possibly the
representative from the Department um
would be better qualified to answer that
question for you he's here okay thank
you representative selig thank you um
I'm curious um a if there are specific
tests you have in mind and B how this
relates to reciprocity with other
states um likewise I think the
representative from the Department um
can answer that question as he deals
with that area
any other
questions seeing none thank
you Steve
applebe good morning Madam chair
Representatives thank you for uh calling
me this morning stepen applebe director
uh Department of Education one of the
programs I oversee as educator lure so
here to offer any Tech supporter answer
any
questions any questions representative
wock morning good to see you again hello
um just to follow up to representative
cell's by the same thing uh on these
licensure exams where whichever ones are
the current phase of Assessments um if
they change they are they L ripped list
listed out somewhere and if they change
after say I take the test this year and
I renew so two part question and I renew
and the the test has changed they have
to take a test again yes thank you for
the question great question um these are
for initial lure only not for Renewal so
um if you're seeking a new endorsement
on your license then you would need to
take a test which is the current
practice today but it would not be for
Renewal renewal purposes so when you
renew your license you would not need to
take that
test follow um see on this section A it
doesn't say initial um so is that
somewhere else in the RSA I've
missed it just say candidates for I
don't see initial or so if we go back to
line five and six such rules should
require all candidates seeking a New
Hampshire
license so we we interpret that to mean
first
time doesn't say renewing it says
seeking so we
okay seeking seeking seeking means
initial
yes thank you thank you m CH
representative s thank you very much and
thank you for taking my question to
repeat the question I I asked
representative cordelli Are there
specific exams that you've identified
and how does it relate to um recip
reciprocity yes great thank you good
question um yes we currently accept
exams from either ETS or Pearson um
those are the two primary uh exam
vendors for educator lure in our country
there are other vendors and we'll take
those we we'll analyze those and see if
they're comparable and we will accept
them uh many states have their own
testing Massachusetts for example have
the mtel exams some of you may be
familiar with those those are really
Pearson exams re rebadged for
Massachusetts and we'll accept those as
well um as far as reciprocity goes um
these tests are portable so if someone
comes into our state state from
Massachusetts and they've taken the mtel
exam and it's it's comparable to our
standards we accept it thank you
y representative
Cornell here thank you for taking my
question so I would assume that they the
state board or whoever would never pick
a test for them to take that wouldn't be
accepted in other
states good question yes I I I don't
want to speak for the State Board in the
future however the way licensure around
the country Works um as I said there's
only a few very very few testing vendors
and it's all about comparability so
there could be a thirdparty test
developed as long as it meets those
State
Standards then it's used and typically
state standards are based on National
standards so all the tests align but
again I couldn't speak specifically to
the Future for the state board but it it
wouldn't it hasn't been the practice
over the years
and I I may have missed this but why are
you asking for this now is it has there
been a problem or so the there's been a
concern other states um there there's
been a bit of whiplash in some states te
testing is imposed and then testing is
repealed then testing is imposed and it
creates a real burden for both
candidates uh the field as well as for
our higher ed um teacher prep programs
because they of course testing is part
of their program and if there's a
testing requirement this year and then
it's repealed and then it's reinstated
you've got folks already in the process
so this adds a little more stability to
that and predictability to that
process representative
bbon thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um two questions
um one is there are alternative pass
certification that might lead to an
initial certification currently do all
paths to certification require taking a
test yes great question so um I'll
answer the second one first ultimately
to to to get a full license there will
be testing
involved um there are alternative
Pathways to go back to your first uh
portion of the question there are
alternative Pathways so that folks who
have different backgrounds who want to
enter the profession can enter the
profession they don't have to go to the
the through the standard you know four
four and 1 half year college program for
Education they can come from other
backgrounds but ultimately as is the
case today they will be required to take
an
exam just to clarify they they do need
to take a test now regardless of the
pathway that is correct um and the
second question along with that is um do
they now have to provide a passing score
and who determines what that passing
score might be yes great yes um they
right now for any candidate seeking
initial lure they do need to provide a
passing score um we have some instances
where we will substitute a test so for
example there is a requirement for all
of our Educators to take a basic
academic skills test it tests eighth
grade knowledge of math writing and
reading and um we will Tak in place of
the standard what people have heard
prais core talked about at times that
that three-part test we will take SAT
scores at the 50th percentile or higher
uh in place of that test so if someone's
taken an SAT for example New Hampshire
our high school students take SATs we
will take that in place of B that basic
academic uh skills
test as far as who determines the
passing score the State Board of
Education currently determines the cut
score and that is typically based again
on a national cut score so again looking
around at reciprocity this way we don't
approve somebody here who goes two
states over and their score isn't good
enough there so we do today um typically
use the national cut score for these
tests but it is the state board that
makes that
determination representative
Hall thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question uh about the CTE
teachers uhu maybe examp on that final
sentence um what is the case right now
for them for the CT that is that is
thank you for the question that is
currently the case Cas they are
currently exempt from testing can
substitute an industry recognized
credential okay so this bold language is
just adding it into the legislation okay
thank
you representative
NATO thank you madam chair uh thank you
for taking my question so on the uh
CTE
uh for them are they basically working
under the umbrella of somebody who's
already taken the tests uh cuz nobody
can give you really the really life
world uh say in a technician's world uh
who's been out in the field recently uh
so they're more than happy to help
youngsters fill their shoes and uh so
and obviously and uh would they be
working under like an umbrella of say
somebody who already took the tests and
everything yes so thank you for the
question so um CT teachers today can use
an industry recognized credential so for
example maybe they have an ASC Master
Mechanic credential they can submit that
in place of standardized testing um and
then as far as once they're in the
classroom they typically have a mentor
uh or perhaps the CTE director um so
there are it depends on everybody does a
little differently right and but it that
does happen today so thank you very much
thank you
representative Bon thank you um one
extra question um do some Educators uh
there's different certifications and
different licenses so some teachers have
multiple certifications do those each
certification require different tests I
mean is there one General test just to
get your licenser and then if you want
to be a a math specialist a reading
specialist are there additional tests
required and would they be subject to
the same uh language is the umbrella
term for everyone that we hand a license
to uh within that there are four
categories
administrators classroom
teachers uh instructional Specialists
and uh educational Specialists right
it's right there in the in the statute
on lines uh six and seven so
um all
administrators and hopefully I don't
mess this up uh all administrators and
teachers are required to take that basic
academic skills test
and then so that's kind of the the
initial test if you will and then if
they want to become a chemistry teacher
or a principle they're going to take
that specific test for that
endorsement and that's that's really a
Content Knowledge Test so if I want to
be a chemistry teacher I'm going to
prove that I know chemistry um know the
content okay representative Woodcock
thank you m chair miss one more to
follow up on the industry recognize
credentialing is there a listing of that
I know you're just talking about the the
mechanic AC but there's a category below
that I mean what defines with an
acceptable industry recognized
certificate yeah thank you for that
question so we work very closely with
the CT directors and the association on
um what what would be considered an
acceptable credential so for example if
someone's an electrician and they have a
license from our state as an electrician
that's an industry recognized credential
um it is a very Broad odd term quite
honestly but folks come to the to the
CTE world with all types of backgrounds
and all types of experiences and
credentials so we work when we have
questions we reach out to the CT
directors the folks that know best uh to
determine
that follow matter here sure thank you
just so if if I was uh a young trades
person uh 30 40 which is years ago and I
wanted to uh prepare
I couldn't for the exam prepare for
maybe getting it to education as a
vocational educator CTE educator
different sorry old term um and I look
online it doesn't tell me what I need to
prepare for right so no listing say we
don't list the exams because they change
okay right we don't not the exams excuse
me we don't list the the the industry
recognized credentials because those
change we do list the exams and you have
the option right saying trying to take
the AL as the recognized industry
credential it's wav okay thank you
that's it
[Music]
okay representative
Freeman thank you madam chair thank you
for coming in front of us um currently
just CT and I'm asking this question
because I think some people are asking
this question as well do CTE instructors
teach any core classes such as language
arts math science Etc thank you for the
question so um the the short answer is
uh they shouldn't be right we have
administrative rules that say they can't
what actually happens out in the schools
we're not the police the certification
please but um we do have administrative
rules that that prevent that it follow
up thank you and thank you again for
answering this question so so basically
what you're saying is the CTE
instructors are there to teach a
specific
skill such as Automotive electrician
Plumbing hairdressing is that correct
correct that would be my understanding
thank you very
much any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you is there anyone else looking to
testify on
this okay we'll close the hearing on HB
e
e e
I yeah I was gonna ask
him thank you um we'll get started with
our next uh hearing which is on House
Bill 384 prohibiting bullying in schools
and uh I see uh for the first time in a
while representative lean here to uh uh
present this bill to
us welcome
back well thank you Mr chairman good to
see you in a new role and
congratulations on your recent
appointment to chair this new committee
did did you say congratulations or
condolences well I was going to wait
until afterwards as far as the
condolences after your testimony after
my testimony sure so for the record my
name is Peter leechman I represent
Peterboro and
Sharon so I'm here to uh this morning Mr
chairman um to discuss bullying but not
to to make any changes in existing law
but to give schools school boards
another leg to at least get parents in
to discuss any uh remediation activities
regarding bullying so there's no change
in the existing statute and as you know
Mr chairman and members of this
committee there's extensive laws in
place right now to deal with bullying
but there's really nothing to prod the
parents or the Guardians in to discuss
consequences so it's pretty simple but I
have received um quite a bit of feedback
uh from different organizations I
received uh a call from the U an
attorney representing the disability
Community where they have found bullying
to uh impact those members of our
community because and maybe um Miss
Rosenberg is here to discuss those
concerns but again my bill is just uh
another if you will a tool in the
toolbox to uh
address bullying in our school systems
and I'm sure I do have some uh written
testimony Al Lisa Walker who was a
superintendent of schools in Peterboro
until she recently moved to Grandam or
is not still living in Peterboro but
she's a superintendent in Grantham uh
she's provided some written testimony
she also wrote a very good OP ED on this
and I've made copies of that and at your
pleasure i' like to distribute that Mr
chairman
what
so with that Mr chairman I really have
nothing
else that was the shortest uh one that
we've had this
year um are there questions uh for the
representative from the committee
representative Terry yes thank you um
thank you for taking my uh question I'm
I'm looking at page two uh line lines
one through uh three
with respect to um the appointment of a
bullying
officer could you talk a little bit
about what what a bullying
officer either is or would be in in
terms of
professional credential professional
training
credential could this
be someone and and then it could it be
someone who's already on staff who holds
the requisite credentials or would this
be determined by the school boards and
the trustees are you leaving this kind
of open-ended with respect to um
credentialing and and um and
training and then
um would would this building
officer would this person be um a a
volunteer or somebody who is paid you
can just talk a little bit more about
that and help me understand the
background for this and what you have in
mind I would appreciate it sure thank
you for my question I must have included
the bill in that package I handed out so
I don't have it in front of me so I
should probably go back but as I
understand it and I'm not certainly an
expert by any means uh schools already
have a bullying officer that's appointed
by the school board uh it's left up to
the school boards as I understand it's
often the school resource officer that
is that person but it can be anything or
anybody and that's how I understand it
but this is just allowing again parental
involvement The Bullying officer is
somebody that's already part of this
bullying statute that allows School
boards to appoint someone I believe at
their disc
discretion well so so with respect to
credentialing and training and so forth
or a program at a higher education uh
institution of higher education learning
uh that that would all be uh considered
and determined by each School
Board ifications would be in your
thinking here I believe that's how it's
handled now great thank you
CH additional
questions yes representative B
Bon thank you uh Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I'm just curious
the um policies you've described a lot
of detail in here of what it should
I know that a lot of school districts
currently have bullying policies have
you consulted with them and how does
that relate to some of the uh bullying
policies that are already in place in
the school districts thanks for the
question I have not consulted with
anyone I've just consulted with the uh
Lisa Walker who was the uh uh person
that asked me to file this legislation
and she's got written testimony that
I've handed out and uh an oped that
discussed this whole issue that was in
the conquered monitor just recently so I
have not discussed it with anybody else
other than Lisa
Walker
sure yes representative
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative lean for coming in front
of us do you know what the currying of
the current um bullying interventions
are I do not to be perfectly
candid follow up I'm I'm I'm going to
ask you some technical questions so and
if you can answer that's fine if you
can't yeah I'll tell you so and I
appreciate your honesty um do you have
any statistics on evidencebased
methods I do not okay I thank you oh
sure yes represent morrris thank you Mr
chair um would the newly mandated
creation of a bullying officer upon a
single occurrence of an incident have to
file a chins petition potentially
escalating a school-based issue into a
Judicial issue
I believe in the fiscal note on the bill
if you look at it and I'm just thinking
back on memory there's already been like
close to 600 have been filed Chin's
petitions already based on bullying so
it's already
happening uh
yes doesn't this bill go above its own
authority in creating parental classes
for the accused
parents I don't think so I I really
believe that should be parental
involvement anyway I would hope that if
parents had a child that's been accused
of bullying they would naturally come to
the school and work with the school
authorities to discuss it um from what I
understand in talking with uh
superintendent Walker that sometimes
that's not always true and that at least
this would really put an encouraging
stick if you will to try to get the
parents yet to discuss the issue with
the
school go ahead thank you I I guess
guess the last question that I would
have is what would be the safeguards in
place to make sure that parents would
actually attend the classes versus just
not showing
up well again to be quite candid I would
just hope that the the parents would
just show up that they don't need to be
encouraged to show up that they would
take the interest in their child to if
there's a accusation of bullying they
would you know come down to the school
to discuss it with school
officials thank you sorry for so many no
not not a problem
um So currently there would be no
repercussions for parents who don't want
to where within this bill if they didn't
want to show up then they wouldn't be
technically required but it would more
be encouraged so there won't be any
legal uh
repercussions uh I don't believe so I
don't believe they're going to be
arrested or anything it's more of an
encouragement to get them down there
okay to the school
sure yes representative Murray thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I are you aware that uh at
least pursuant to um
193f um five sub paragraph B it does say
that there are already educational
programs required for pupils and parents
in preventing identifying and responding
to uh incidents of
bullying I do have a copy of the
complete statute here and I guess I was
aware of that yes thank you sure yes
representative s thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I
just am looking at this list of of
classes that are in I guess encouraged
for parents to take the definition of
bullying or the impact of bullying or
the root cause of bullying and I'm
trying to understand how attending one
of these classes will change the
behavior and so I wonder if you might be
able to elaborate on
that well I think any uh the more
information the better decisions so I
would hope that someone's attending a
class that they may you know pick
something up that would help them to
address bullying issues okay and may ask
pa um separately from this from work
that I did on a subcommittee over the
summer what became clear is there's a
lot of
um uh there are times when things that
one might consider bullying other
administrators or teachers might
consider just mean
behavior um and I'm I'm curious how um
this bill would do anything to help
clarify or distinguish that or have any
impact on that I don't think it would
but again um I would just be guessing
that it would or
wouldn't any forur the questions from
the
committee see none thank you very much
representative for being here today oh
not a problem thank you Mr
chairman uh next uh Karen Rosenberg from
the disability Right
Center good morning chairman cordelli
and members of the committee my name is
Karen Rosenberg I'm the policy director
at the disability rights Center which is
um New Hampshire's protection and
advocacy system for people with
disabilities and um although I think
that this bill was really well
intentioned I'm here to actually speak
in opposition to the bill our office um
does hear from parents whose children
have disabilities and have been
victimized by people who've been bullied
we also hear from parents and I've
represented kiddos who experience
disability especially disabilities
involving communication um autism
spectrum disorder those kinds of speech
language issues who get accused of
bullying and are investigated for
bullying and um maybe subject to school
discipline about this and what concerns
me is that
we we have a law in place already that
requires schools to have policies that
Define bullying that at Point usually
it's a principal or their design to be
the person who would investigate a
bullying incident there are resources
that are made available to schools
around bullying that are supposed to be
shared with parents and students um to
set expectations there are
evidence-based interventions to deal
with school climate and school culture
and I think that one thing that's really
unfortunate is that parents don't always
participate in these programs they don't
always they're not always engaged with
their students and with schools in the
way that we would want them to be
optimally and I can understand that it's
very frustrating for schools when they
are attempting to address bullying to
take care of all the students because
that's what this Law requires they're
supposed to be taking care of the needs
of both the person who's the victim of
the bullying as well as the bully to
look at why they're bullying a lot of
bullies have been bullied themselves and
um that's why they're doing this or
maybe they don't know any better and so
schools are making great efforts to do
this and I can understand how it would
be very frustrating on the part of if a
for a school provider to like try to get
a parent involved and the parent doesn't
the parent doesn't support them the
parent doesn't come to the meetings
these things happen unfortunately though
I think although this may be a problem I
don't think this bill really addresses
it the kinds like a conference having a
school conference inviting parents those
are all things that are permissible
under current law so if that is an
appropriate intervention our current law
would enable the principal or their
design to have invite the parents
they're actually required to call both
the parents of the P the kiddo who's
accused of bullying as well as the kiddo
who's been victimized so they have I
think 48 hours to do that they can
Implement their policy they can have a
conference that they think that's
appropriate they can implement the
school's disciplinary
code and I don't think that this is
going to change parents Behavior I think
certain some parents no matter how much
a school district tries are just not
going to and and it would be lovely if
we could um make sure that people could
get out of work and you know whenever
they need to to go to school meetings it
would be great if we could resource our
schools in such a way to provide more
opportunities for them to engage parents
and provide the the teachable moments
that our children need to learn about
the impact of bullying and how they can
hurt their friends unintentionally and
make right by their friends it would be
really great if they had the resources
to do that um that's asking a lot of our
schools and they may not have the
resources to do that and what I'm
concerned about is that by creating a
position of bullying officer which um
might someone like a school resource
officer who's not trained in
evidence-based interventions or how to
improve School climate or how to engage
parents is going to now be in a position
of sending more kids into our Juvenile
justice system and I don't think that
that's going to necess that that's not
going to address the problem at hand
it's just going to take more kids and
potentially take them out of school when
they should be having their education
delivered
because you know courts functioned
during the school day and now they're
going to be in front of a judge and
treated signed a juvenal parole
probation officer and and now they're
going to be further criminalized
marginalized um instead of being talked
taught about what it means to be part of
a school Community what the expectations
are and being folded into that so those
are my concerns um and I I think that I
don't deny that there's not that a
problem seems like there is a problem
with parent involvement but I don't
think this is the solution so for those
reasons I would ask you to um not pass
this bill and I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have thank you
questions from the
committee
yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um it it's uh pretty disturbing when you
see a lot of bullying cyber bullying I
know somebody personally years ago lost
an 11-year-old child to suicide because
of that uh are there any studies or any
we doing any proactive in New Hampshire
now that I'm unaware of well I know that
the Department of Education receives
bullying reports um it would be great if
they could do more to look have the
resources to look deeper
into if there are like if there are
certain pockets of bullying or schools
where it's not being resolved
appropriately
it would be nice if they could do that
I'm not aware I mean I think someone
here is there is someone here from the
Department of Education who can speak to
what they do with the data but um in my
knowledge I I'm not aware of any
extraordinary efforts to look into this
particular districts where there's a lot
of bullying and um yeah it's it's
terrible and it is really challenging
schools are faced with challenges when
um we have Electronics available to our
children um which allows them to
hopefully use hopefully use them for
good communicate with us when we they
need a ride home from soccer practice
but could be used for other
purposes thank
you any further
questions see none thank you very much
for being here again thank you
all and we have miss larby and miss
McCormick from DCF to provide some
information thank you for being here
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Susan laraby and I
am General councel and legislative
liaison for
DCF good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Amy McCormack I'm
the juvenile um Justice administrator
associate bureau chief at juven at
DCF we're here to answer any questions
that you may have in regards to the
changes to the child in need of services
pursuant to RS say 169 uh D that is
before you because I realize that it's
quite a um dense and and lengthy um
statute that many of you may not be
familiar with in this committee compared
to a juvenile justice committee or a
child and family law committee and I did
want to speak briefly uh about the
fiscal note I think there's some U
misunderstanding about that but if we
could just briefly explain to you the
juvenile justice system which is under
DCF so the juvenile justice system
includes
169b which is delinquency and that is
for children under 18 who if they were
an adult and they committed a
misdemeanor or a felony in the adult
World they can be held accountable in a
delinquency petition proceeding in front
of a juvenile justice uh
Court 169 D is child in need of services
the acronym is chins which is a child
who meets specific definitions of that
Chin's statue and as it stands now the
chin statue is to summarize a child who
has repeatedly been truant from school
due to their own willful conduct b a
child who has been uh habitually running
away c a child who has committed if they
were an adult multiple violations of the
criminal code or d a child who is and
this one's very lengthy so this one I
will
read who has a diagnosis of severe
emotional cognitive or other mental
health issues who engages in aggressive
fire setting or sexualized behaviors
that pose a danger to the child or
others and is otherwise unable to
receive or ineligible or unable to
receive Services under a delinquency or
a child protection um petition under 169
C our fiscal note was basically if a
Chin's definition now included uh and it
is defined on page two lines 11 through
13 of a child who has committed a
subsequent Act of bullying or cyber
bullying investigated by The Bullying
officer and determined to be an act of
bullying by the perpetrator
against another
pupil and because this is a brand new
definition we are basically making an
estimate a best estimate as to how many
children that would affect especially
because page one of the bill says that
the bullying officer shall file a
petition alleging that a child is in
need of
services what we have now is many um
cases coming into juvenile
Justice through schools and that was our
estimate because there are already many
school-based chins in terms of repeated
violations and of course the treny one
so there is no definition yet in the
chin statue that includes repeated act
or I'm sorry a subsequent Act of
bullying so we are making a best
estimate as to how many um new cases we
would expect to see due to the addition
of this definition of
chins I will also note that the
definition of chins as well as all of
169 D speaks to the before a petition
can be filed the
person who wants to bring that petition
first must bring in the Department of
Health and Human Services and have it
have what's called a voluntary Services
assessment done and Amy can speak more
to basically what that means what a
Chin's petition actually is in terms of
uh again that is bringing a child into a
courtroom and assigning them an attorney
and it is a child in need of services
not it's again I will Amy now speak to
that so when a case comes in to the I'm
sorry I'm sorry um when a case comes
into the Department of Health and Human
Services and it's assigned to a juvenile
probation and parole officer for an
assessment to be completed to determine
the need for voluntary service Services
as part of the existing child in need of
services statute so that probation
officer would go to a residence of that
individual would engage with that child
and that parent either the parent or the
child can refuse to engage in that needs
assessment which would then end that
current assessment and allowing that
District who's sending us that referral
the ability to bring that child to court
and file a petition in court proceedings
then that attorney would be assigned to
that individual the matter would then be
scheduled for judicial oversight and
then that child would be assigned a
juvenile probation and parole officer
through the court system that child
could end up on probation as a result of
that matter and then be subject to
conditions of probation that they would
then have to follow through which would
include ongoing regularly scheduled
review hearings and monitoring of those
rules of Probation and ongoing case
management of of that child by the
probation and parole
officer and again we're happy to answer
any further questions you may have
against uh regarding the juvenile
justice system in particular the child
in need of services um thank you very
much uh representative Murray thank you
Mr chair for taking and thank you for
taking my question so I I did have a
question regarding chins in addition to
the juvenile
uh probation officers and all of those
things uh would there be a requirement
for a guardian at lium on behalf of the
child as well uh for the child to help
navigate the system or no there is no
requirement under the Juvenile Justice
statutes for Guardian at liem to be
appointed to the cases
involved representative Woodcock thank
you Chell good morning thank you for
than the
question as I hear you explain the the
statute
uh and then the involvement in the
Juvenile Justice program what I didn't
hear and I may have missed it because I
miss a lot I may have missed it I didn't
hear you say what we're doing for the
youngster in terms of mental health work
counseling other Alternatives in Li of
just uh entrance into the justice system
and probation system is there any part
of that statute is there any there for
the youngster for the
student you mean prior to a petition
being filed is there other interventions
that are able to address those issues
that a child may have once once the
child is uh referred to you from the I
would be under this 11 12 13 section
once the youngster is referred to you
and gets into your system but I didn't
hear anything that was not legal ad
Justice they didn't hear anything for
the
youngster do you want to speak to
voluntary Services consist sure so when
the juvenile probation and parole
officer goes and meets with the family
at their residence that there would be
an assessment completed utilizing the
child adolescent needs and strengths
tool If the child and the parent is
willing to engage in that assessment
that tool is a tool that identifies
strengths and needs of that child and or
family as a whole um and then there
would be recommendations made as to what
service or intervention would be
provided to that child and the parent
those individuals have to agree
voluntarily to participate in those
Services if they agree to participate in
those services then yes there could be
in um counseling that is offered there
could be a recommendation for that child
to participate at a local mental health
um Agency for that counseling there may
be a recommendation for a online course
um depending on what is presented in the
actual assessment would drive the
outcome of the
recommendations the Juvenile Justice in
general um I don't know if folks are
aware has undergone significant
transformation over the past last five
years in really embracing Prevention
Services and utilizing community-based
supports as a first line of intervention
for our children as the outcomes that
they are um receiving would be more
improved by having earlier intervention
services which are not necessarily
driven by Juvenile Justice but informed
or utilized prior to involvement with
us
yes thank you I appreciate that when you
mentioned Services prior you you didn't
really get into that depth and just to
be clear so if I understand that both
app parent and the young student child
has to agree to participate and if they
don't then that terminates that
assessment and then that move them into
the more the judicial area correct okay
thank you so much thank chair can I just
clarify one piece to make sure they were
all clear I'm sorry can I piece thank
you um the the child and the current
chin statute must have accessed some
form of community-based intervention
before acceptance into DHHS for a
Voluntary Assessment to be completed so
the current statute identifies wanting
to have children and families access
community- based supports that exist in
their communities as a first line of
intervention before involvement or
referral to Juvenile Justice in any
capacity for voluntary Based Services
yes thank you Mr chair so it sounds like
this bill would be jumping over that
step and leaving out that communitybased
intervention and going directly into a
chin
petition I do believe page two lines six
through eight uh briefly touched upon
what's required in the Chin's petition
and again the Chin's um statute was
quite wordy so I will just highlight one
section that says that any petition
filed by a school official must contain
information that shows that this legally
liable school district has sought to
resolve the express problem through
available educational approaches that
the school district has sought to engage
the parent or Guardian in solving the
problem but they have been unwilling or
unable to do so that the problem remains
and that Court intervention is
needed so it does take into account 169
D five Roman numeral five uh expressing
that again before a child is brought
into court the school must exhaust all
communitybased
uh problem solving of this again because
the last the last resort should be the
school especially I mean should be Court
especially in light of what Amy said all
that we have done to prevent a child
being brought into court thank you yes
and I will note too that this this stat
this bill is silent on the age of the
child um the it is silent on the fact
that um chins and delinquency already
counts for the child who has committed
what could be either a violation a
misdemeanor or a felony so of course if
a bullying is uh including criminal
threatening harassment any acts of
violence that's already um part of the
Juvenile Justice
System um with the um fiscal note it's
uh indicated that there have been
448 uh chins referrals made by school
districts um so those were made by um
one of the other uh subar paragraphs in
D2 other than what we're adding here in
terms of bullying correct I don't have
the number in front of me but I would
assume that 95 95 are that first
definition uh um acts of willful truancy
95% 95%
yeah any further question
questions see none thank you very much
thank you
time is there anyone else who would like
to uh
testify um on uh house Bel
yes Ed up on my table oh okay
hi Nancy Beerman New
Boston um I was at a parent meeting last
night uh for sau19 and um I brought up
this bill uh
because we are um also concerned about
some behaviors in the in the school
bullying was not one of them um because
in our school in our school board has a
policy
jic um it's 10 pages long and it
includes like every single step and I
feel like our community and our school
board is taking care of bullying and um
and has been taken care of um things
that are being presented here and I
again I'm concerned about students being
put into the juvenile detention system
um because this bullying and and all the
aspects that are being put on the
parents uh for this um our school
district does a really good job and I
think that if you look at other school
districts um because this policy
definitely probably came from the New
Hampshire School Board Association um
and they followed along with it and
added their own little twists because
every Community does have their own
needs that um I don't think that this is
needed um and so I would like you to
vote against this um I don't like the
fact that this policy also assumes that
the current school policy doesn't
include parents our school policy has a
lot of parent involvement in it and um
so that's all I have to say thank
you
question um uh I see we have people from
the Department of Education and uh the
school boards Association does anyone
have any questions for U either of them
who might provide some
answers um Miss Fenton could you talk a
little bit about the reporting that is
required by the
department good morning for the record
my name is Diana Fenton I'm an attorney
with the Department of Education and I
appreciate the last speaker who left the
light on for me so I didn't have to come
up here and fumble the ball once again
um so the Department's role in bullying
is is fairly limited uh perhaps narrowly
tailored is the better word for it so
the department does receive uh
complaints about bullying instances of
bullying and what the department will do
is reach out to the school district
reach out to the family and the the
general each case is unique obviously
but the general approach is that the
investigator for the department will
reach out to the school district and
inquire if they are aware of the
instance in the report if they have a
policy that addresses bullying and if
the policy comports with the state
law there can be instances again every
every case is so fact dependent will
commun unate with the family see if
there's a resolution that can be reached
um so sometimes the department can kind
of act as an informal mediator in that
sense
but legally the extent is to just
coordinate with the district make sure
they have a policy and that it complies
with the law and that the school has
followed that
policy every year in November the
department presents reports on on two
particular issues that catch attention
the first is restraint and seclusion
which we have discussed in this
committee during my presentation that's
governed by RSA 126 U that's the annual
restraint and seclusion report and at
the same time the department presents on
bullying we compile those numbers from
the school safety report which is an
annual report that the schools fill out
and we present those
numbers again the Department's role is I
use the term narrowly tailored uh we
review those numbers we report out on
those numbers to the State Board we
provide those reports on our website and
to this legislative body the general
court in terms of our
review you know for restraint and
seclusion and I recognize restraint and
seclusion is not the issue right before
this but those reports are kind of tied
together so forgive me if I if I go a
little bit astray for restraint and
seclusion if we see an abnormality in
the numbers if we see a very high number
or a spike um we will reach out to the
school and inquire we do the same thing
for bullying but those numbers are
different restraint and seclusion you
can see if and I I will pick on my
alamad kennet high school so forgive me
representative Woodcock um but if kennet
High School one year has five instances
of restraint and seclusion and the next
year has 25 we're going to reach out to
kennet high school and inquire as to why
that is is there an issue with uh
reporting is there an issue with the
definitions and and the faculty not
understanding what needs to be reported
it's different however when you look at
bullying because bullying is between
students right it's not about restraint
and seclusion and and faculty putting
their hands on kids and so those numbers
for bullying are always high we identify
what trends we see I believe this year I
don't have the the numbers right in
front of me but I believe this year we
saw the Middle School numbers go
up and you know during the pandemic we
noticed some Trends obviously the
numbers went down and then in the years
when the kids went back to school we
noticed a huge increase in the numbers
and that's really the role the
department plays in terms of identifying
those overarching Trends I'm happy to
take any questions and as always I
appreciate your time and I really admire
everyone who followed my advice and
brought their book in I'm just glad I
brought my own book and followed my own
advice any questions representative
Woodcock thank you thank you attorney
senton I borrowed her book this morning
oh yeah well I didn't want to say
anything representative Woodcock but
there's always one I was working on it
last night at home um I think I'm
misreading sure the statute um on
looking at nine uh SE line nine of the
first page and it's referencing 194f
11 I probably miss you know I did take I
read your training twice I may I still
couldn't find this
correctly is that the correct are they
citing the correct statute
there is it 194 or 193f this says 19 I'm
looking at uh D line nine on the first
spot 194 f11 they're talking about the
bullying
officer and I kept on coming up as the
education trust fun I must have been
doing it wrong
so the version I see in front of me and
I have House Bill 384 pulled up
electronically I I see on page two line
one I see a reference to 193 f11
bullying officer yep I'm looking at line
nine
on line nine I see in the are you on
page
two of the bill I'm on the back to the
first page
okay so I agree with you the high the
school bullying officer appointed
pursuant to 94 f11 I think you're right
I think that's a
misprint right I think that's an inappro
incorrect cross reference that will
bring you to the wrong statute that will
bring you to the EFA
statute you should be in RSA 193 F1
would be a new section
created I agree with you yes I think
that is simply a scrier error follow up
Mr CH and I want to thank you because
your training I saw that last night
thank you well thank you very much I
appreciate that I'm glad you saw it
because I didn't so thank you very much
are there any other
questions represent
Cornell I The Bullying is reported
through a program that whoever does the
discipline in the school fills out and
then sends to the so that's correct
changes could be like a new assist
principle that has
different definitions of what they want
to call things or is it subject to human
error or judgment it could be
representative Cornell we see that more
with the restraint and seclusion we see
that more with restraint and seclusion
because as as we talked about in this
Committee in the training the
definitions of restraint and seclusion
are very complex right we saw that in
126 U where it says what it is and more
importantly what it isn't however I
think that we can always account for
human error um discretion as to what
gets reported what doesn't what gets
documented and what doesn't we don't see
that as much with bullying as we see
with restraint and seclusion I think
those numbers speak louder to us in
Restraint and seclusion than in bullying
but I will say that I think um when you
rely on people in a certain position you
have that inherent discretion as part of
it
yes for the questions
I see none thank you very much thank you
very
much anyone else who wanted to
testify
okay um and Miss Fenton and um pink card
also
yeah good morning chairman cordellia
members of this committee um it's nice
to see those of you that I have not yet
met I'm Becky Wilson I'm the director of
governmental relations for the New
Hampshire school boards Association um
happy to provide any information or
answer any questions in regards to
Schoolboard policy around this
issue uh there was a mention of a policy
in New Boston I believe um is that are
you familiar with that policy number and
is um that a standard policy from the
school board Association thank you for
the question representative yes policy
jic is pupil safety and violence
prevention that is a required policy as
part of the bullying law here in New
Hampshire um it does lay out very
specifically what the New Hampshire
definition is of bullying um it lays out
the investigation procedures at the at
each district uh school districts and
school boards need to agree on their who
is going to be their bullying
investigator or the bullying officer I
believe was what it was called earlier
um what the procedure is for
investigation um there is always
conversation that happens regarding the
difference between
um bullying incidences that are reported
versus founded incidences of bullying
this definition is very specific about
what is considered a founded incident
basically of bullying so often you might
hear community members or people talking
about um lots of incidences of bullying
while that may be the casee in terms of
what is happening not every case that is
reported becomes a founded invest
founded case of bullying that does not
mean that it is not mean I think to some
of the other Representatives comments
earlier does not mean that people are
not fighting or kids are not being um
hurtful to each other and that there are
some in some you know uh interventions
that need to take place to address those
kinds of issues but not every um
incident that is reported becomes a
founded in incident of bullying based on
the definition uh there are also other
sample policies and forms that go along
with jik in terms of reporting forms
bullying report forms and Schoolboard
notification of bullying
reports thank you you're
welcome yes representative Terry thank
you uh now that we know that um that
these sample policies um exist can you
give us some sort of an idea of how
widespread their usage is um across R
the state by school districts not
necessarily all of them in total but
that there is some degree of um
utilization by school districts thank
you for the question representative
Terry jic is a required policy by the
state for every single School Board must
adopt a policy around bullying
investigation and Reporting um this is a
sample policy as I believe the speaker
prior spoke to District we offer sample
policies to member districts to adjust
to some extent based on the culture and
their Community needs um however there
are parts of those policies that are
required by law that must be addressed
somehow within that policy so every
Local District School Board should have
this policy thank you you're
welcome representative Woodcock thank
you chairman K good morning good to see
you again back um as regards the term
bullying officer is that is that a new
term I mean I haven't seen bowling
officer I've seen Desy principal Desy I
mean a variety of pieces is that defin
somewhere or is I just missed that as
well uh thank you for the question
representative Woodcock I would have to
go back specifically in C and
193f um if it's designated in terms of
what the title is but each school
district and School Board does need to
identify who is going to complete the
bullying investigations in most cases I
believe it calls out the principal
specifically however I'm sure they could
designate somebody else um to somebody
else's previous comment regarding
whether or not it's the school resource
officer there are also I would just
caution people to assuming excuse me
that the school resource officer if
there is one would also be the bullying
investigative officer because there are
times where School District procedures
need to be separate from police
procedures um and I would just want to
be cautious that um that may not be the
case for bullying officers where the
school resource officer may or may not
be able to fill that role based on those
differences yeah thank you so um
appreciate that I probably should have
asked attorney Fenton when she's up here
but I I can't I hav that ter bullying
officer just is jumping on my C I've
never seen it uh in terms of rsas or in
school administration as granted as you
said someone's designated and it may
happen to be a police officer by Happ
stance but that's so I was just trying
what it say refer it to that I didn't
know we creating a
new category or somewhere else to refer
to thank you for the question
representative when I do a quick word
search for the word officer under 193f
it doesn't appear at all in that section
thank you this twice did I'm
right yes representative
litfield thank you and thank you for
taking my question in light of the fact
that you've mentioned that jic exists it
is a
requirement do you have a stance on
whether or not you feel this bill is
necessary does the New Hampshire School
Board Association support or oppose this
bill thank you for the question
representative Lichfield it's nice to
see you um we're not taking a position
on this bill as it's currently written
um I think that you know from a
procedural standpoint involving families
and having family engagement Whenever
there is any kind of incident um where
students are at risk on either side it's
important to have parental involvement
um however there is a lot of crossover
as I think you've heard from previous
speakers with uh other departments other
um systems that would need to be
involved in this I think having um
parents at the table as I'm sure you've
heard me say many many times is very
important in these conversations whether
or not uh this bill
accomplishes um it's real getting rid of
bullying in our schools I'm not I don't
I don't think we're taking a position on
that no other questions thank you very
much thank
you so I guess that will'll close uh the
hearing on House Bill
384 and um we will uh break for for
lunch and reconvene at 1
p.m.
e
e e
okay we'll uh start up for our afternoon
session we have uh uh two hearings and
then an exec
session um the first bill that we will
hear is House Bill
446 and uh the um Prime sponsor is our
own Committee Member representative
Litchfield welcome thank you Mr
chair good afternoon so this is
regarding House Bill 446 again my name
is uh representative Melissa witfield
out of Brentwood Fremont Danville this
bill came about simply because of a
constituent request right now as it
stands in the public schools if any
non-academic surveys are given out to
the students the parents are to be given
10 days notice and it is to be an op in
the parent had simply requested that
instead of a link being attached to the
email that the actual survey be attached
to the email so that the parents can
view the survey on the
spot I am also planning to offer an
amendment today that I'm going to pass
out right
now I'm just going to wait a moment
until you each have a copy please
we have problem here take care of it
ser
okay so the dis of the amendment is just
simply the fact that right now there is
an exemption for the CDC youth risk
assessment survey right now the parents
do not have to opt in it is an opt out I
am requesting through this amendment
that the committee agree that we go
ahead and we change that to an optin
we've heard a lot out there about how
maybe some of the kiddos aren't taking
this survey quite as serious as maybe
they should be and I know there's a lot
of important data that we get from it so
the goal is right now to um provide the
same the parents with the same courtesy
that they're receiving with all other
non-academic surveys that is the 10-day
notice um along with the optin but this
also would give the parents a chance to
maybe sit down with their kiddos and say
hey this is a very important survey we'd
really like you to take it
seriously thank you
questions representative Woodcock um to
the chair yes I may I'm looking at the
amendment um thank you by the way and it
significantly Alters the initial bill
and I'm concerned that if we take this I
don't know how you're going to rule on
it re we take this now in in process
then there seems to me there' be a lot
of folks and organizations that may want
to dialogue about that particular
Amendment we won't have an opportunity
if we hear it to today yeah we're not
going to um execute
today um but if yeah but for example uh
representative if if I if I belong to
group X and I want to speak on this I
won't have a chance to do that is then
this is a major function of this bill
right just so just I'm put out there
that a concern I have already okay thank
you yeah I'm G try and take that into
account work something out thank you
um uh there was um the original Bill had
another change in it too do you want to
um just touch on
that are we um discussing the attachment
of the surveys to the
email uh yes yes right okay so right so
what would happen now is if this bill
were to pass any non-academic surveys
the parents will be notified 10 days
ahead of time but they won't be just
given a link to the survey there'll be
an attachment on the email of that
particular
survey represent Murray thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so in looking at lines 13 uh
through 15 which is in addition to the
non-academic survey I'm curious to know
if that the term academic survey could
potentially include things like um lunch
request forms or any other type of of
information that is necessary for the
daily functioning of Learners to sort of
participate in their daily goings on in
the school Community uh so that's that's
the first question I had about whether
or not that could be interpreted in that
way
so with this amendment in HB
446 um all I have done is taken out
lines 10 through 13 I believe 13 14 15
are already in existence at this point
in
time oh I'm sorry I I understand I'm
sorry I understand what you're saying
I'm sorry I read the amendment and not
the bill yeah I was referring to the
initial underlying
bill I would have to get back to
you yes thank you Mr chair and then um
again uh continuing on in lines 13
through 15 my question um is to whether
or not it says that you are requiring
communication through email and quote
any other means of delivery the district
deems appropriate so in the way I'm
looking at this is it possible that the
district could say that's all we're
doing is email and that's that's it
that's all or is there what is the other
means the other means is courtesy of
OSS um we we had discussed this earlier
and I I think the feeling had been
probably it's 2025 probably most people
would have an email by this point in
time follow okay I'm
sorry
further
questions no okay thank you very much
representative uh representative Henry
is it Geeson gas
thank you Mr chair honorable
Representatives uh for record
representative Henry gon Hillsboro 29th
District
Goffstown so I'm a co-sponsor on this
bill and one of the things that I try to
always reinforce when we talk about
notification to parents especially from
public schools is that these children
unless they are ward of the state are
the sole um responsibility of their
parents their parents are the only
people who can recommend Health Care get
Behavioral Health get counseling assist
the children medically speaking and
legally speaking if there is an issue
and if the parents aren't notified of
non-academic surveys or any other places
where issues may be identified and the
parents don't have the means to take
care of their CH their children
appropriately there's no set of
circumstances where the government the
government's teachers public education
who who do work for the government
should be the sole Proprietors of a
piece of information that is not shared
with the parents unless there is an
imminent risk in which case the law
enforcement should be notified
immediately so I'm coming to this from a
perspective of transparency for the
parents as care providers for the
children the public education system is
a great system but everything that they
do that's non-academic should be clearly
transparent to the uh parents as is
everything that they do that's academic
thank you for your
time thank you uh questions for the
representative yes representative Morris
thank you Mr chair it seems to me that
uh like questionnaires about school
lunches would be exempt for this um
particular bill as to the designated def
the definition to designate elicit
information about the student social
behavior Family Life religion politics
sexual orientation sexual activity drug
use or anything along those lines is
that
correct I would not first of all I mean
respectfully I've never seen a
questionnaire about what you would want
for lunch um but that would occur to me
uh to be a day-to-day operational thing
in support of Education now with that
said I don't see a reason why a a family
wouldn't get shared a survey on what's
available for lunch if they have
specific dietary needs that the school
may not know about or may know about so
I don't see a reason why we would hide
that from the parents but I also don't
see that as an outlined relevance within
the bill um
sir
no uh I just point out that the uh the
uh list of um information on line
1718 um are taken uh from a federal
statute for federally funded uh
surveys um that was put in with the
original bill uh back a number of years
ago represent of sik thank you very much
and thank you for taking my question um
I'm just trying to think about these
surveys in the context of my child who's
been in a High School Sociology class
and obviously with sociology they're
studying different things so the
students in the class designed surveys
that they used with their peers within
the building that were not academic
right it might be about movies it might
be about um whether the the roller
skating I don't know you know but
specifically because they were learning
the skill of completing sociology
experiments so these would be
non-academic surveys for the purposes of
the students improving their in the
class generating things with those
surveys by by the statute need to be
sent to parents 10 days ahead of
time uh thank you representative by my
understanding as long as that was part
of the course curriculum which was
outlined and given to the parents in
advance that would be within the scope
of the class follow up please yes thank
you so it but the surveys were given
beyond the students in the class right
they were given to students like you
know through other programs through the
advisory or through lunch during the
Lunch Period or whatever so that they
could elicit information from their
peers for the purposes of compil
learning how to compile data right like
just as an example maybe they surveyed
to determine whether Mor kids like
pepperoni eat pizza versus make your own
sandwiches you know so that's a
non-academic survey being used for an
academic purpose so I'm just curious how
that would fit with this
bill representative my advice at that
point in time would be to air on the
side of caution and make those available
to the parents um because they're being
used out of the scope of that specific
classroom and among the general
population that's how I would interpret
that um just from a prudent standpoint
to prevent any questioning of morality
or litigation
what
Nancy Beerman New
Boston
um my major concern with this bill and
I'm all for restricting more um is that
we need to have some more teeth to it um
in
2024 um school year um I'm sorry 23 24
school year I requested on right to know
asking gtown high school for all surveys
and questionnaires that they had given
to students at the beginning of the
school
year um that was 113 Page Long document
that I received
so the school district knew about this
law they knew about the rules they were
still allowing the teachers to do
this um questions ranged from asking
about knowledge of a subject or skills
for that subject matter some of them
asked about their favorite foods colors
don't know sure about why that had to be
there um but then it also moved on to
more personal questions asking students
what their pronouns were and what
gender um there are also links to online
surveys that we don't know if that third
party was collecting that data and using
it somewhere
else um there was also questions asking
which was your preferred parent to be
contacted well both parents if there's
two parents everyone should be contacted
if there's an issue um in one uh paper
that was from a uh teacher they asked
for the students cell phone number not
the parents the student one I reported
this to the Department of Education um
the school district um was told that
they needed to do more training with
their teachers and that was
it so there's no incentive for this
school district to do or not do it um so
this year 2425 school year I again asked
for a right to know uh my school
district is um not happy when I do right
to know requests because the immediate
response I get from them is we'll get
back to you in 90 days with your answers
um when I uh submitted a email to the
Department of Education about this
refusal of supplying the information
until 90 days um all of a sudden four
weeks later I got the information again
this year whereas last year it took two
weeks um this year there was 24 pages of
information um so teachers are still
giving questionnaires and surveys um
thankfully the personal information was
not uh provided and not asked for this
time so I was happy to see that um there
was no information about social behavior
Family Life religion politics or sexual
orientation or drug use or anything else
so they are with the training following
but again they're still giving the
surveys so I think there needs to be
more clarification to the school
districts more training and um there
needs to be something more I think if we
sat there and we did write to know
request to a bunch of school districts
you're going to get surveys uh and
questionaires from teachers that um
asked questions that they shouldn't
because the parents don't know that
they're not supposed to be asking and if
you're wondering why I asked our school
district about this and started it was
one parent came up to me she was new to
the district and her son came home and
he's like Mom why is this teacher asking
me about my gender and so she rep
replied to me she contacted me and I did
it because she didn't feel like she
could as a new parent to the district um
and unfortunately most of the teachers
that were doing the questions about
gender and sexual orientation and
pronouns were the science teachers so
again there needs to be more bite to
this thank
you thank you questions representative B
Bon oh I never get questions you do now
oh my
goodness uh thank you for taking um my
question uh you mentioned that you
submitted the right to no request to get
the um the academic nonacademic surveys
so um the the law says that the parental
permission is required so are those
surveys that you're mentioning um did
they say that the parents weren't did
not give permission for those there were
no parental permission given or asked
for on any of it never that's that's
what the School District said told you
yep
yep any further
questions now you can go
okay uh next um an Marie
Banfield good afternoon
um my name is Amry Banfield I'm a
parental rights Advocate focused on
excellence and education I've been
advocating on behalf of parents in
education for about 15 years and I come
here in support of HB
446 so I've been here longer than this
actual law so I can go back in history
and answer any questions in terms of how
the law came to be I was very involved
with the original Law and this is why we
need to expand the law and include the
yrbs um years ago students were asked
highly sensitive and personal questions
on surveys distributed for by for-profit
vendors so for-profit vendors were
gathering all this information because a
lot of these surveys uh come from online
vendors parents were shocked to learned
that their children had been asked
controversial questions on sex drugs and
alcohol usage in one case a father in
Bedford said that because of these
surveys his child learned how to get get
high sniffing
glue unfortunately the yrbs only
requires notification appearance by
school
Personnel since the questions on the
survey are sensitive in nature parents
should be required to
consent the power school breach should
have been a wakeup call to
everybody this information is very
vulnerable to attackers hackers
notification does not go far enough and
a notification may never be make it to a
parent that's the problem sometimes it
does sometimes it doesn't the first
questions on the yrbs surveys are
tracking questions children have written
their names on them and they use their
unique pupil identifier number on them
because they think it's a test and so
they turn it in as if it's a test
in Bedford years ago too a parent
demanded that his child survey be
destroyed after he found out his child
took it without his knowledge the
administrator did confirm that they
destroyed the survey if it was Anonymous
how' they manag to find
it there should never be a license to
void privacy rights to collect personal
data for researchers or other government
bureaucrats public administrators and
bureaucrats will always be asking for
things that will make their job easier
or for a little more money essentially
opt out makes the Assumption an entire
family voluntarily gives up their
privacy rights this is
wrong the private sector when it comes
to survey the industry standards and
best management practice require optin
that is the standard there is no
justification to carve out a special
standard for schools when it comes to
the issue of parental rights and
privacy so in addition because this has
come before legislators in the
past um I have additional testimony now
this will identify prior
legislation um but for instance this one
is
from a medical professional Doctor Who's
talking about why the the uh the survey
the ybs does not have IRB approval which
it should to make it a
valid survey so this does not have IRB
approval that's all explained in here uh
it's it's not valid kids take it for a
joke they they just randomly answer
questions it's not in a in a um
scientific setting so he explains all of
that in here in
addition uh in the past John Depetro who
is a well he's pretty much a privacy
data privacy expert anybody who knows
him knows that this is what he deals
with this data privacy and he explains
in here how this data is not
protected and that this is also subject
to um a breach or a hack or something so
again they are giving the surveys the
surveys will be given they're not taking
it away with this all we're simply
asking for all they're simply asking for
is to make sure the parents consent so
when a student is asked about their
sexual activity or their drug usage or
if they've um you for instance uh a
question three if they've attempted
suicide and sometimes people feel so
depressed about the future that they may
consider attempting suicide for
themselves or killing themselves this
may not be what a parent wants their
child to answer and so if I knew that
notification was getting to every parent
and that every parent had the
opportunity to look through this and
make sure that this is okay for their
child because to be honest with you a
lot of parents are going to be okay with
this they're going to be fine with
taking this survey but there are going
to be some that are not and it is time
to respect those parents instead of
putting up a strong arm and driving them
out of the public schools so I think
that's another factor to consider so I'm
happy to answer any questions if you
have
any thank you
questions see oh yes representative
Freeman yeah thank you and thank you Mrs
Banfield for coming in front of us um
since I I do know that you've been um on
the leading front of this for many years
do you have any sense of what happens to
that data after the surveys the
non-academic surveys are
completed uh so there's a difference
already in law they have to get parental
consent on non-academic surveys so
that's already in law are they getting
them on cupcakes lunch of course not
that we we discussed this with the
original Law this was not the intent of
the original Law to you need to get
parental Comm permission if you want to
have a cupcake party in your school this
was specific that's why we even added
the language in there that this is about
the student social behavior this is
sensitive private information that
they're asking about go read the survey
go at look at the questions their life
their religion their sexual orientation
their sexual activity so that was
discussed with the original BT so so
we're already
through that and yes um I had uh one
school district that did have a have a
student go around and uh survey other
students so I read the survey I looked
at the survey to make sure that it's not
asking about cupcakes in in a social
science class but there were highly
sensitive questions in what a student
was going around and asking their
friends now this is information going to
a student
in the school about sexual orientation
maybe that child doesn't want to reveal
that maybe that child will say no but
the point is this was a way for parents
to also look at kind of controlling the
information that comes out about their
child in a school setting um it's a lot
of information it's a lot of data I
don't know if that answered your
question but um if not I'm happy to
expand on it
seeing nothing further thank you very
much okay thank
you Jama
Wilder sorry uh good afternoon my my
name is Jam Wilder and I'm from Campton
New Hampshire um thank you for allowing
me to speak on this um I am in support
of this bill um I want to share my story
with you uh a few years back my older
two children were in school when they
gave the youth risk assessment survey
and at the time the law was that it was
an opt out option and that was by law
that the school had to give them 10 days
notice uh to decide whether or not they
wanted their child to take it my school
illegally uh gave the the test to the
children and I got a phone call from
both of my kids at school uh horrified
at what they were being asked and I'll
share some of those things in a moment
but a week following that uh survey we
had a suicide in our district and there
are six questions about suicide and Mar
read one of them to you that are very
very leading and um plant a lot of seeds
for kids that might be struggling with
depression so I wanted to um I followed
up with the school and I asked them to
share the survey with the district so
that other parents would have the
opportunity to speak to their children I
waited one year after this happened and
tried uh to explain what was going on at
a a school board meeting and I gave I
read the six questions at that time the
parents there were so upset to hear what
they were asking the children and said
that I was attacking the parents that
they started screaming at me shut down
my mic and didn't allow me to continue
so I just want to let you know in that
survey they don't even they ask
questions about whe your sexual
orientation and abuse and suicide and
Body Image but things like where do you
look for your pornography or do you look
at it and then list all of the places
that they can find it the drugs like
that they list there were so many that I
had never even heard of as a parent and
I had an experience with my daughter who
struggled with body image issues after a
survey given in a doctor's office and I
want to bring this to your attention
because I think often times we think
we're doing something to help other
people and not realizing how much we're
damaging children by giving them
information they don't know how to
process and so I'm pleading with you
that you would pass this bill and make
it an optin option for the Youth risk
assessment survey because these kids a
lot of them don't even know how to have
a conversation with anyone else and
these ideas are now planted in their
heads and they don't know how to process
them and so for to protect our children
and to be able to have real
conversations about where they're at I
ask that you would give this information
to the parents and allow them to protect
the children thank you thank you very
much for coming today
questions
anybody see none thank you very
much Emma
shery good afternoon members of the
committee for the record my name is Emma
savini I'm the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new futures
um I want to first start off and say
that I am not here in opposition to the
underlying bill I think um new Futures
wouldn't take a position on that um I am
in opposition to uh the amendment that
was offered this morning or this
afternoon um that would remove the
exception for the Youth risk behavior
survey um for information purposes um I
think there are a lot of Advocates um
mental health uh substance use disorder
um and otherwise youth groups who would
be really interested in weighing in on
this particular Amendment and I think
they should be off heard the opportunity
to speak um secondly I would just uh
underscore the importance of the data
that we get from the youth risk behavior
survey if it were to turn into an optin
um survey we know how difficult it is
just to get field trip permission forms
back let alone um a permission slip for
something like this um so I think the
amount of of parents who would um even
have the knowledge that there's a
permission slip going home um about this
uh they wouldn't have enough data uh
from the survey to produce reliable
results um and folks rely on this data
um to ensure that we have um targeted in
interventions in our schools for kids
who are suffering from mental health
issues bullying um healthy eating I'm
trying to think of all the the great
programs that stem directly from ybs
data it's also really critical for um
people like me to be able to to track
the data so that we know what
interventions are working and I can help
inform you all uh legislators about
exactly what um policies and procedures
would be most beneficial for our
students um I'm happy to take any
questions again I'm going to uh send
some written testimony to follow up with
all of you about the amendment um and I
believe uh and I'll send this as well
but I believe a few years ago a similar
bill was introduced and there was a
group of students who sent in video Tes
that was really powerful on how they use
the ybs
data thank you very much yes
representative Freeman thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
I'm going to ask you the same question I
asked Mrs Banfield do you have any sense
of what happens to the data or after it
is disseminated sure thank you for the
question M uh representative um I
believe the department is here and they
would be able to clarify more
specifically but my understanding is
that the school collects the data it is
completely anonymized and it's uh when
it's been taken and then it is
aggregated so that um there's no way for
the data to be tied to a particular
student um and then the data is used by
um the school the district and the
department um to inform those programs
that I
mentioned thank you res representative s
thank you so much and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned that
the school uses the data to improve
programs or to create to work with
programs could you you just give us a
little bit more detail about how those
programs benefit um students sure um I'm
thinking in particular of schools that
have um data on um you know bullying
let's say um we heard a bill earlier on
bullying I think the ybs data can
uncover instances where schools maybe
have students who are experiencing
bullying may not feel comfortable going
directly to a teacher to say um I'm
being bullied but they can say in this
Sur and anonymously say I'm being
bullied and when the data comes back and
shows that this school you know 20% of
students have reported being bullied um
the school can Implement um programs to
help change the culture and climate of
the school and make it more um friendly
to all students so I think um in
particular students really appreciate
having this opportunity to ask for help
anonymously um while while they don't um
get that individualized component
because the data is completely Anonymous
um if enough students report something
the data can show
that yes representative the dve thank
you for taking my question thank you uh
so what you say I agree with um
but when students opt in you get that
data thank you so much for your question
I I want to just be really clear that
when parents have to opt into something
in other states in other districts where
that change has been made there has not
been enough um opt-in participation
because parents get so many pieces of
paper a day so many you know things they
have to respond to a lot of times things
get lost in the shuffle we are hearing
from Educators that it's hard getting
things back that students want
permission slips to fund field trips
even that is hard to get back so um
where there is not enough participation
in the survey the data is not reliable
and so we wouldn't be able to use it to
inform these programs follow up thank
you um can you give me an idea of like
percentage that you need to make a
reasonable deduction from something I do
have that percentage somewhere I'm sorry
I don't have it off the top of my head
but I can definitely follow up with
you any other questions see none thank
you very much thank you
uh
sha Yeah Yeah from Health and Human
Services good afternoon I'm Abby Rogers
I'm the legislative Lin for the division
of Public Health
Services for the record my name is Jo
cholo CH I a Hui C d a WLA I work for
the division of Public Health Human um
Public Health Services thank
you thank you uh we were here to monitor
the bill today we we um we're not going
to take a position on the underlying
bill but uh we do have some concerns
with the amendment propos Amendment
language so we were here to discuss that
and answer any questions that the
committee may have uh relative to the
yrbs youth risk behavior
survey question oh I'm sorry you want to
offer some yes so New Hampshire elim ybs
since
1993 uh starting
1915 uh 2015 excuse me we did uh we
started the the school sensus survey
which to survey all the public high
schools uh for student from uh Grade 9
to2 for
ybs um currently ybs has two format one
is electronic format one is paper format
depends on the school's uh preference
and their resource uh most of the
schools uh based on our um approach our
Outreach most of schools are taking
electronic surveys uh which means that
there's no way that they can put their
um confidential uh information or
personal information on the survey it's
so click next page click next page um
for example um we do have several
schools that a few schools that that are
still taking um paper survey however we
do the uh training uh to train the
schools to that the students know know
that uh they should not write anything
other day their answers on the answer
sheet so when we distribute the school
uh to the papers for the paper format
there is the questionnaires which is
print out and also another part is the
answer sheet answering sheet that has
ABCDE on it students will just do the
circle when they hand out the um the the
their result they handed out the both
the questionnaires and also the uh sheet
and we collect the answer sheet so we
did educate and and um that uh Trend
School administrators and coordinators
to let them know that pre distributed
information that students should not
write anything other than their options
to the questions uh the other part on
the um parent consent form and also the
questionnaires uh ybs is administrated
in od year so 2021 2023 and this year
2025 we have started ybs survey already
um prior to the survey eared about
around October or November dhh has
posted the questionnaires for the next
year on our website uh for the public to
access um we also let the schools know
that uh feel free to download the
questionnaire from DHS website posted on
their own school um website or just to
embod embedded the link to their
school's website and we also provide up
our form to the schools and ask them or
encourage them to do the Outreach to the
parents uh for the up out form uh in
order to take up in approach we did have
uh one or two schooles in the past that
they used opting approach however in the
next survey cycle this back to the up
out approach the reason is that they
didn't get their school level report
because for uping approach we were not
able to produce not only the U
meaningful overall aggregate statistic
report but also to the school level
report we were not able to provide them
the school specific uh report for uh the
schools to to to take a look at um all
the options excuse me all the survey
result that the student performed over
in
answered
um so yeah sorry sorry sorry yeah so we
just wanted to clarify too that um as um
Brianna uh the other speaker from new
futures um mentioned as um you know for
the commissioner of DHHS has a road map
2025 um and that is specifically
focusing among other things on
Behavioral Health uh to ensure that all
youth in the grand State have um the
mental health um services that they need
and a good uh children's system of care
so for the the 2023 results that were
released um from DHHS and I think it was
in coordination with the Department of
Education for um the 2023 results it did
show um Market um some challenges in the
in New Hampshire with um youth mental
health and the ybs is an intrical tool
for the Department to track um and to
try to address uh you know serious
issues of depression 40% of students
reported they had persistent feelings of
sadness or hopelessness in 2023 um even
though that was a decrease uh from 44%
in 2021 these kind of figures give us
some tools onto where you know what how
to address that and how to better help
um to improve youth mental health um so
the percentage of uh students that we
are able to help is greatly improved by
the data that we receive from the yrbs
like how how is New Hampshire doing a
snapshat on what school districts might
need additional assistance with students
looking at um issues of nutrition um
bullying as as the previous speaker
mentioned and uh able to have the
department assist with um looking at
just like what is the state of Youth
mental health um with students I mean
that's a hugely important thing as we
move forward um into this new 2025 when
there will be another um youth risk
behavior survey and as chawee mentioned
um it's just crucial that the department
um be able to receive this important
data on a snapshot on how how youth are
doing in New campure with mental health
it's critically important for the for
the for those students and also for the
future of um school districts and and
how they might be uh best able to
address those needs if I may
sorry so um so for the questionnaire it
has basically six topics uh including
the sexual behavior and also U mental
health it also include uh alcohol
consume or alcohol excuse me uh risk and
also injury safety like whether um you
know you you you put a seat belt or o
helmet while you ride a bicycle or
driving or drinkle driving or tax
driving this type of injury or safety uh
question is it also ask about uh how you
feel about yourself whether students uh
voice is important to the community or
to the school whether you know school
should uh take into account the the uh
The Voice or the comment from students
this type of question
so it has a variety and also included
physical activity nutrition Etc so it's
not just focus on um sexual behavior or
mental health but it has a variety of uh
questions in in among those six topics I
just want to emphasize that and the
questionnaire uh selection is based on
um the CDC standard questionnaires pools
that we um each state if they are y BS
we will select at Le 23 from the CDC
standard pools and we are not able to
change the question wording because um
it focus on the time Trend if there's
some wording change we are not able to
do the time Trend so for the
questionnaire selection and also what
topics are included uh it's it's very is
very
broad any questions representative drive
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i' I'd like to follow up on the
previous um speaker that asked when we
asked about how much data makes good
data I mean what percentage do you need
to do
that um that's a very good question and
thank you for the question so for the
survey we look for the survey data or
analysis we do look into um whether this
a reliable or not reliable we do have
um an algorithm to do the statistic
analysis to compare the confidence
interval so if there's only few survey
then the confidence interval will be
pretty big and then we are not able to
compare from one area to the other area
if there is a more uh sample size that
is reliable then yes so U Back to your
question I'm I'm not able to provide
like a you know
10% sample or versus 90% sample of
course 90% sample SLE would be better so
um and the concern on the up in is
really about we will not be able to get
enough sample size in order to generate
the meaningful and statistical uh
analysis for specific indicators or
major H
up okay so you're you're narrowing in on
it but that really doesn't tell me
enough is enough but what's
enough um it just doesn't seem like
and how much do you think you would lose
from between opt in and opt out I think
how many students we will lose is that a
question yeah so um currently most of
the Stu uh schools excuse me are taking
up out approach so typically um for ybs
we need to have
60% uh of students who take the
surveying order to get 60 yes and that
counts not only the student
participation but also the numbers of
schools in that um uh in the public
health regions um so that the two Factor
time together in order to get 60% so for
example if in one Public Health Region
I'm just taking maybe greater National
as a example um sorry I don't have top
uh the number of top of my head how many
public schools there but but if it only
has two schools out of five schools that
are using uh taking ybs or commit that
they will do
ybs if there are 100% of student for
those two schools complete the survey we
still won't get the Reginal data because
it's less than
60% so it's not just about the student
participation it also about the uh
School participation and while bsso uh
voluntaries so we don't put a mandatory
that the school needs to
participate thank you that's thank you
represent Murray thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question I think
you started to hit on something that I
was thinking about and you you mentioned
the regionality of of maybe results or
findings it is there through the yrbs
are there data informed decisions that
would change potentially
regionally I'm sorry if I un your
question correctly uh are you asking
whether the result will change the
regional prevention programs
or um so for this part I am not the best
person to um talk about how the data is
used because it's being used for various
programs and also Public Health regions
uh in New Hampshire on their preventions
um and also maybe um the local
communities to look into their own
Regional data and also some schools are
willing to share their data with public
or public publish post their result
online and then the Schoolboard or the
um parents will be have will have the uh
opportunity to look at the school data
but as far as I understand it focus on
prevention so like a tobacco use like uh
sexual behavior and like what Abby
mention about mental health to find the
support so um for Department
uh we did publish some kind like a uh a
b show or Q&A where if you if if you are
seeing this um questions or if you have
this type of um concerns please contact
this hotline this hline so we do have
that type of information posted on our
uh website and this was this is the
result from uh one hearings regarding
ybs bills that we uh take a serious to
see if what type of services or
resources the department can provide so
we do have that uh resource for for the
general public to be able to look into
our students if they want to look for
some kind like a resource for them
themselves sometimes they may not have
um you know um an ad doubt that they
they can trust or they rely on to
discuss their own um concerns then that
part is what we what we distribute build
and and available on our website in
terms of how programs look use the data
overseeing the data I think the um
partner from new future has uh provide
some information and if we we can follow
up and then provide more information how
how progr areas are using the data or
how the local uh communities are using
the
data thank
you representative
Balon thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um there has
been brought up some concerns about uh
student data privacy um and how and and
the vendors that that you use to collect
this information how is this uh data uh
being the Privacy being contained and um
how confident are you given that there
have been data breaches and other um
formats that we've seen as power school
has been brought up for how how do we
know student data is
safe uh thank you for the questions so
first of all ybs is a nominal so we do
not collect any personal informations we
do collect or the survey does collect
which grade you are in uh and also your
height your weight and gender etc those
are the basic demographic information
that we collect uh and so for the
further uh statistic analysis for focus
on different type of uh demographic
group um among the students um excuse me
so we currently have a vendor that uh we
utilize to administer ybs for both
electronic survey and also the uh paper
survey for electronic survey we are
using recap application which is a hipop
compliant um software that um using to
collect the data uh for the electron
um format it does not capture any
personal identifiers and for school over
the classroom ID which is randomized we
do have the school ID we we know so we
know which school is from the classroom
ID is randomized um uh based after the
school submit their uh class roster and
then the department randomized the the
the school ID so the school ID and also
the um class ID are captured into the
record but it's randomized so we have no
way without looking into specific form
to know where um you know those those
group of Records is from in terms of a
security and privacy approach uh whether
the school is taking electronic format
or the paper format
we um require the school in the class
room setting they need to have at least
five students taking the survey at the
same time so if if on the survey dat
there are only four students or two
students in the classroom we ask the
school or the school coordinator to
merge or group those student in with
other classroom so the classroom setting
this to have at least five students in
the classroom and the classroom setting
need to be separated so they won't be
able to Peck other people's screen over
to look at what other people are are
answering so that is the safety um
approach and to protect privacy and
confidentiality that we require the
schools uh to take um as this type of
approach and how confidence the data is
excuse
me is secure first of all it is a ninous
so um I personally do not believe
there's a way that the school or the uh
teacher will be able to identify which
one and then take it out uh that that
that's not even though that's what we
have heard uh during the hearings but I
I don't believe that I don't I I don't
believe that is feasible and for the
electronic uh format we did get one or
two request to remove one record or two
record we are not able to do that so in
order to do that that we will need to
remove the entire classroom or entire
School record then that means there's no
survey for that specific
school thank you thank you
representative celik thank you and thank
you for taking my question um would it
be safe to say that um because this is
given at the the specific survey you're
addressing as given at the high school
level that students at the high school
level may not disclose information to
their parents about their current mental
health feelings or their current um drug
or alcohol use or their current sexual
activity with their parents and might um
that the survey might identify that
there's a an area where there's
significant uh risk behaviors occurring
that might need to be addressed in the
community without identifying targets uh
yes that that is correct so we do
encourage students to talk to um if they
have any concern to talk to um any
adults that they trust May that may be
their parents that may be their
guardians or maybe uh School teachers um
so so for for the survey we also
encourage parents to look into uh our
questions or questionnaires online
however we also um we do not encourage
the parents discuss with the student
prior to the surve but after the surveys
definitely to to to understand oh uh
what do you think about this question
how do you think um how important do you
think your voice uh should be heard by
the school Etc um this this type of um
discussion we do encourage um parents
and and and student to talk to the um
you know uh to talk to each other and
for for the surve the purpose is is to
hear the true voice from the students
and sometimes this is something that we
probably cannot get like a just as face
by face for per se so this this surve
this survey excuse me provide a a
mechanism for the student to answer um
we we we would like to have their
truthful answer on each questions uh
another part that I I I didn't I forgot
to mention I think it's very important
is the survey is voluntary so students
can up out themsel out any time if they
do not want to answer any question they
do not need to answer they just skip it
skip it um the only requirement that we
have is in order to provide um protect
the confidentiality and privacy once the
survey start student will need to sit
there until the survey ends they don't
need to do any questions if they are not
comfortable with this question or
provide their answer so that is another
um information that we uh as the school
to distribute to the student prior to
the survey that they if they don't feel
comfortable answering any questions they
can Skip and we don't know who Skip what
um because we want to have the truthful
answer another um uh PRI privacy
mechanism that we take I fail to answer
provide that information is that during
the survey uh period of time no one can
walk around the teacher cannot answer
any question from the students the
teacher cannot walk around either the
teacher will be there uh and once the
survey is complete over the time is up
student hand back if it's paper survey
hand back there answer sheet uh if it's
electronic survey they just click submit
and then for electronic survey we
provide access code to each student we
don't know who will get what access code
um and once the survey is done the
access code will be invalid they will
not be able to take the survey home and
answer they have to answer it uh during
that period of time that uh School
identified or set
up representative
Freeman thank you madam chair thank you
for coming in front of us and answering
my question actually two questions if I
may thank you um how long has this this
survey been administered how many years
have we been U participating in this in
New Hampshire for New Hampshire we uh
started doing this in
1993 and in the past it was the
collaboration uh between DHHS and the
Department of Education and starting
2025 uh it's it's it's purely elimary by
DHHS so starting 19 93 New Hampshire has
been participating in
yrbs thank you and may I thank you um
you've stated numerous times that that
the survey is completely
Anonymous if that's so how do we alert
parents if specific problems come up
with each student in other words if
there are problems why wouldn't we be
able to alert the
parents I'm sorry
you you stated numerous times that the
survey results and the survey itself are
completely Anonymous there's no personal
pupil identifying number on those now if
there are problems and say there's an
alcohol problem with one of those
children who has filled out that survey
why wouldn't the first line of defense
be to go to the parents and let them
know that there's a problem instead of
taking all this information um
aggregating it and just sending it out
into the ethos why wouldn't we be
alerting parents
um thank you for the question uh I guess
I would say on that is it is supposed to
be an anonymous survey it's a it's a
aggregate data of what is going on in
the school um as part of the par
parental permission for taking the
survey uh which we provide to parents
they are they have access to the survey
they have access to questions and um I
guess best practice would be uh to maybe
you know if you had concerns as a parent
be able to discuss that with your
children or discuss in general if you
were going to um if your child was going
to take the survey to to maybe um it
would be a good opportunity to talk
about some of those subjects that might
be problematic without you know sort of
calling out an individual student
because for our purposes it's a general
public health um healthy of health of
the community the school Community
without singling out children or or and
that in it in itself would be sort of a
privacy
concern well thank you madam CH and
thank you for answering my question um I
I do understand what you're saying um
however the parents are the first line
of defense so I I am curious as to why
we wouldn't have a mechanism in place to
alert a parent if a question on that
survey is problematic to that student if
they're having suicide radiation I think
that parent should be alerted
immediately but by this mechanism it
can't be because it's completely
Anonymous so the point I'm trying to
make is is there any way number one that
we could add a layer of notification
even though it is anonymous um or you
know number two um maybe this
information isn't as Anonymous as we
thought that's basically what I'm trying
to yeah thank you for the questions so
basically um the survey provides some
data to understand what's going on in
the specific schools and also specific
communities if there is any um survey
result that shows that this Community
has high percentage of student who
consider or who has considered suicide
or who attempt suicide then yes that
will alert that um in order to I mean to
alert the the parents in of time that
would be the efforts from the schools
and also maybe the local community uh
program areas uh to do so uh for the
survey is to provide some supporting
um numbers or data for their own
work I know I probably don't answer
before answer your question I'm sorry I
wasn't rolling my eyes was rolling at
the phone like you what can you call me
later representative Cel thank you I I
had a follow-up question from my
questions earlier and I appreciate you
taking my questions so we're looking at
this as aggregate data about a
particular school and this maybe follows
up with some of the other questions that
been asked if we're identifying for
example you talked about a mental health
Spike uh issue Spike over the years
which makes sense especially as a parent
of teenagers during that time so would
that data then allow a district say the
the red School District um to say okay
we've just gotten this data that shows
we've got a 20% increase in students
saying they're experiencing mental
health challenges we need to think about
allocating our school budget to ensure
that we've got more mental health
support or we've got some more training
for our teachers and how to manage the
situation and also create some kind of
Outreach for our greater community so
our parents can learn you know can
identify ways to support their children
and and have conversations because maybe
the parents don't know how to have the
conversation yes absolutely and that's
what we would like to um schools or the
community to utilize this type of of a
report but the bottom line is we will
need to get enough simple size in order
to provide this type of statistic
analysis or to the school or to the
certain
communities any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Aubrey fredman
uh Madam chairman committee members um
auy Freedman liveing Bridgewater private
citizen I speak in support of this bill
um parents need to know well first of
all on these
surveys why are they even wasting all
this time on it when the proficiency
rates are so low especially in math and
science but okay they they do they've
got them they're in the schools that's
that why shouldn't parents pay attention
to what's in these surveys have you
actually looked at them I've seen them
they're actually a little bit better now
I've been looking at them for a couple
years I've been going to school board
meetings for several years and they're
not quite as nosy as they used to be the
middle school is 50 questions and the
high school is 85 it used to be I think
like 110 or 111 for the high school
really nosy questions asking about what
goes on at home Home
Fighting uh Firearms really nosy but
here I want to just read a couple the
Middle School you would understand high
school already they're they're older
Middle School this is from the middle
school and I looked at the 2025
version number 33 H again this is Middle
School have you ever had sexual
intercourse number 34 how old were you
when you had sexual sexual intercourse
for the first time 35 how many with how
many people have you ever had sexual
intercourse 36 the last time you had
sexual intercourse did you or your
partner use a condom I'm not stupid
enough to think that middle school kids
don't have sex they probably do but I
think this is outrageous and they do ask
questions about you know how many
carrots you ate and how many potatoes or
whatever they're not interested in that
stuff trust me they want to know about
the nitty-gritty stuff EXT and about of
course sex and you know sexual
orientation and all that identity stuff
what business do they have asking all
those questions and I'll tell you why
they because I've been going to these
school board meetings for years and I
I'm telling you whenever the question
comes up about the youth risk uh
Behavior survey uh people get all
excited whoa they're doing it again the
data is coming out they just can't wait
for it why do they want the data to show
that the kids are so messed up up we
need to hire more staff more Health
experts to solve the problem the kids
are so messed up how can they perform
academically when they're so messed up
and I want to give an example of how
they do this stuff too because they love
the youth risk behavior survey thing um
just pull on up
here okay they like to cherry-pick the
questions that make make it look like
the kids are actually doing worse than
oh I can't find it so I'll just remember
it there was like a question about
smoking and one question was um how
young were you when you smoked your
first cigarette or something like that
and you know nine or 10 or 12 or
whatever gives you various choices and
the next question was how often do you
smoke a cigarettes you know every day or
once a week or whatever so clearly the
second question would be more relevant
somebody who's a habitual smoker would
be of more of concern that somebody just
like I actually smoked a cigarette when
I was 12 or 13 I never smoked again but
if I answer the survey the first time I
took it would be more you know and
that's the kind of question they use for
justification because I saw it on a
presentation on the youth risk behavior
survey I mean pick the most irrelevant
question of all the the first time you
did it and then maybe you never smoked a
cigarette again they want to show and
again they cherry-pick the questions and
answers to make it look worse so that we
we got to hire more
people um okay what else I I on the I
think the there is an amendment I
haven't seen it I guess to strike the uh
the youth risk behavior survey so that
um there's an exemption right I believe
so maybe I'm wrong but if there isn't
there ought to be the youth risk
behavior survey is the worst one of them
all it's the granddaddy it's the nosiest
and they just use it to further uh
basically hiring more people and I don't
and I think it takes away from the
academics to be quite honest spending
all this time on stuff so I do think
it's a good uh bill I support it uh the
clearly the uh Amendment about um taking
out the um you know parental consent I
wish parents would actually look at
these you know realize what's going on
but you know you can't force it but at
least you have to get the consent and I
think they also mail out all that stuff
at the beginning of the year and they
don't uh I don't think parents pay that
attention so I think this particular
thing should be sent separately through
emails and it is true a lot of people
don't open emails anymore so even then
that might not work maybe they have to
mail it I don't know personally I don't
think they should be wasting the time on
it but parents need to get the full
consent and actually see these forms and
if they okay them then that's that and
and that's any questions representative
Murray thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question you did I hear you
correctly that it's your understanding
that the notification is sent at the
beginning of the year to families
through either a letter or a parent
portal or something of that nature it is
my understanding that there's a bunch of
stuff sent early in the school year
which you would expect and that this is
one of them um just in a flurry of
papers and that's um and I don't think
parents pay much attention to that I
could be wrong but I think something
like this that ask all these nosy
questions should be sent separate ly and
actually get a respon and should be opt
in that's another thing too this opt out
to me it just doesn't
work representative
wock thank you m chairman good to see
you again Mr fman it's a pleasure um
just the one question repeatedly you
kept on saying they they they they they
who are they the administration and
school board members who support
having more and more staff more and more
turning our schools into hospitals so
specifically it's been
Administration people on the okay thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you thank you Becky Wilson
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee for the record I'm Becky
Wilson from the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh we are not taking
a position on the underlying bill um I
have not really um had time to really
look at the full Amendment uh language I
just was here to offer uh information
regarding Uh current practices or answer
any questions if there are any about the
Schoolboard policy which is a required
policy I for non-educational and
non-academic questionnaire surveys and
research um and also to just offer um
some additional resources to the
committee regarding the yrbs uh New
Hampshire school boards Association for
a long time has had uh a resolution that
is affirmed annually by members um that
opt in for um Ser for curriculum
programs and this particular survey does
create an additional burden on the
district that's not to say that parents
don't have the opportunity to opt out of
curriculum or programs or surveys that
they don't feel um they would like their
children to participate in if you do go
to the DHHS uh yrbs website every single
question for the survey is published on
that website there's also a document as
well that looks at every single question
and provides a rationale of why that
question is being asked as well as lists
um references for data that is
supporting why the question is being
asked um given that it's given twice in
high school um I do believe that the
majority of districts do post on their
website or send home at the beginning of
the year as part of the paperwork
notification that the yrbs will be given
out um during the I think even years
where it's not part of the um procedure
because it is only given every other
year um the middle school yrbs just to
clarify is not funded by the state that
is a locally funded uh yrbs assessment
in New Hampshire if a district is
deciding to administer the yrbs at the
middle school level that is a local
decision that school boards have to vote
on and support so there's opportunity
there but that is not um the same as the
high school yrbs requirement here in the
state where the state is funding um in
conjunction with the HHS to provide that
that survey um and most School districts
do share the results their local results
of the yrbs at a school board meeting
when those results come out so that
there is some um Community information
regarding how that data is being used
what it's being used for um as I think
many of the previous speakers prior to
me mentioned um it is not solely used by
school districts per se um although it
does sometimes work in conjunction with
other Community Resources to provide
access to needed supports for families
and students across the community so um
happy to answer any other
questions anybody have
questions seeing none thank you Becky is
there anybody else looking to testify on
this
okay representative Edwards
uh thank you madam chair I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31 Auburn Chester
candy and Deerfield um just wanted to um
make one point as a a former certified
information privacy professional and a
10year active member in the uh uh
International Association of privacy
professionals I worked for quite a while
in Corporate America and worked a lot
with marketing people and uh in the
commercial world it's considered highly
unethical to do anything but uh require
an opin to the collection of personal
data um opt out was always viewed
as unethical and so I've been trying for
four or five years to switch the culture
of the legislature in the state from
doing optins to excuse me doing opt outs
to optins because optin is the ethical
way to behave and I wanted to make the
point because the that issue came up and
we have some new freshmen uh in the
legislature but that's it thank you any
questions
for no thank
you okay what we're going to do is
recess this hearing because we have we
just got the amendment today and there
may be more public testimony on this
because it does change it quite a bit so
uh we will recess to a later
date going to go into the next hearing
um HB
415 removing requirements that schools
provide menstrual products in restrooms
and I welcome the prime sponsor
representative perel welcome back to
education thank you very much represent
our chairwoman Noble is a pleasure to be
back in this
room for the record I am um
representative Katie Pell um Carol
district 6 the towns of wolfboro and
Tuftonboro I am here to present um House
Bill 415 FN which is repealing
RSA 1891 16-a because it is an unfunded
mandate so according to um the New
Hampshire Constitution part one article
28a states that the states shall not
mandate or assign any new expanded or
modified programs or responsibilities to
any political subdivision in such a way
as to necessitate additional local
expenditures by the political
subdivision unless such programs or
responsibilities are fully funded by the
state or unless such programs or
responsibilities are approved for
funding by a vote of the local
legislative body of the political
subdivision now this bill is relating
specifically to menstrual Pro um
supplying free menstrual products in
restrooms I certainly don't have an
issue with that my issue with this bill
is the unfunded mandate portion of it so
if you were possibly in looking to amend
the current Statute in 18916 a ran
numeral 1 um it says the school district
shall you could strike that and create a
May in there um if you go down further
in the current statute to Roman numeral
3 this is where the unfunded mandate is
and it says the school district shall
bear the cost of supplying menstrual
hygiene products um and then it goes on
This was um the next sentence was added
in to temper the first as I saw when I
went back and looked at the original
hearing on this bill from or on this
statute from 2019 um and the second
parts of the school district May seek
grants or part so they have the
opportunity to look for outside sources
without um taxpayer funding
specifically um I had one question from
um the public I understand that there
have been at least 3,000 online
submissions regarding this bill um I
have received very few comments
addressed to me personally but one came
up just the other day and it was a good
question um because the woman who
emailed me she was looking at the fiscal
note so first off I was impressed that
someone from the public was reading the
entire bill um but she was concerned
about the line and the fiscal note that
says the to the extent school districts
choose to stop providing such products
um I really um doubt that school
districts would choose to stop doing
that they're already paying for it right
now um so my recommendation to her and
when I responded to her email was that
she check with the school board find out
how they're funding it right now and
whether or not they would continue to
choose to do so should this bill pass as
written and I think that covers
everything thing that I wanted to cover
on this bill so if you have any
questions again I'm specifically
concerned that it's an an
unconstitutional unfunded mandate the
problem is not the products being
supplied any questions representative
dve thank you and thank you for taking
my
question do you have an idea what a
fiscal note would be if we had
to pay for this no I do not okay you can
do it in your
time any other questions representative
Bon uh thank you for taking my question
have you heard from any school districts
um that are opposed to doing this or
have any problems with the
law personally no um oh one other thing
that I did want to point out is that
in
2021 uh House Bill
276 actually tried to make this bill
better by um in section Roman numeral 3
adding in accordance to with article 28a
of the New Hampshire Constitution the
state shall not mandate it basically put
article 28a into the current statute but
that bill didn't pass the house
so representative CK you very much Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um do you have any idea what
the current cost is to any District no
no I I would recommend to constituents
that they find out I mean it's already
in the School District budget I doubt
it's a line
item okay and and prior to this bill um
the original bill which which D also
directed schools about where products
were to be
located was there uh any information
that you were looking at that had to do
anything to do with cost again I have no
concerns other than the fact it's an
unfunded mandate
representative
Freeman thank you madam chair and um I I
do believe that representative Edwards
has an answer to a question about the
money yeah he's going to testify next oh
thank
you representative Hall thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
are you aware of any other legislation
all all categories that have unfunded
mandates that are concern I'm just
curious is this the only unfunded
mandate out there that this became a Hot
Topic I appreciate your question I
highly doubt it's the only unfunded
mandate for some reason it's one that
pops up quite regularly and it was my
turn this
year representative Murray thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question I'm rereading article 28a that
you uh reference regarding unfunded
mandates and one of the questions that I
do have is whether or not um the
interpretation is open to understanding
that it is it's an either or for state
or local municipalities to
fund um it says a vote of or a vote of
the local legislative body or political
subdivision so it doesn't require
necessarily the
state it it puts the onus on either the
state or a local political subdivision
well if the state mandated
this they didn't necessarily have to
take a vote at the school board on
funding this or the town didn't not
necessarily have to take a vote on
funding
this oops sorry yes thank you so so my
question though was it does say or it
the local does it not yes but I would
suggest that over the course of time
this has been pointed out quite
regularly as an unfunded
mandate representative Woodcock thank
you I just want to follow but welcome
back by the way oh it's so good to see
you representative pleas to see you okay
uh I was noticing you said it was I was
going to fall represent Hall's question
but you must have seen my notes um this
is six
years six years of unfunded mandates
across this
legislature and you this one one bill
comes out I'm amazed how that could
happen I don't know it's just one of
those that keeps popping up there are
have been multiple attempts to correct
it make it better and um in fact that's
how I got into this I saw an attempt to
um make it better
and the conversation ensued and here I
sit oh thank
you any other questions
thank you thank you very
much representative
Edwards uh thank you madam chair I'm
representing Jess Edwards representing
um Rockingham District 31 Auburn Candia
Chester and Deerfield um I'm I'm here
today uh as a co-sponsor of this bill uh
initially uh I was sponsoring my own
bill uh and I pulled it when I I found
out that this one was going forward uh
why was I sponsoring my bill well I go
to my school board periodically before
bills are due and I say I'm here to help
what would you like me to do to make
things better and this time around they
gave me uh four action items we talked
about one of them them just being
impractical so they dropped it they gave
me three others and this was one of them
uh principal Lori Collins wanted to be
here today to tell you directly her
request to remove this requirement from
law she said that in all her years as an
educator this was never an issue would
never be an issue and that uh it's
offensive in a way to a expect people
that we entrust the education of our Ed
the education of our children to to be
too stupid to understand that our kids
need this service in the schools and in
fact this service has been in the
schools for probably as long as there's
been commercial feminine hygiene
products so um she did testify on a
similar Bill last term and made the
request to remove this as a a compliance
issue um it actually passed the
education committee passed the house
went over to the senate senate committee
killed it thought we were going to get
it passed so the the reason this keeps
coming up is because when it went into
law uh it seemed to
intentionally want to stick its finger
in the eye of the New Hampshire con
Constitution you you you can't read it
any more clear that the school district
shall bear the cost of supplying the
products uh that's both in one short
sentence a mandate from the state and in
the same sentence a Prohibition of the
state paying for it this is just
offensive and all of us have taken an
oath to defend the New Hampshire
Constitution so this is actually a very
simple bill for us to fix it shouldn't
have to come up every year should have
been taken care of a long time ago now
there are a couple of ways as the
previous Bill sponsor said to fix this
is to remove the mandate to say may
instead of shall provide or just strike
this sentence because this sentence is
offensive the school district shall bear
the cost of supplying menstrual hygiene
products um
in I I have previously submitted a bill
back to the cost issue I've submitted a
bill in Prior terms to actually have the
state pay for it because this is this is
a good thing to have for our girls
perfectly great thing to have but if
we're going to have a mandate we have an
obligation a duty to pay for it so um
there was a fiscal note on that bill and
I think for the
entire Bill I'm going for memory um it
was about
$550,000 a year for the state um that's
in the historical record we could pull
it up we can see what the old fiscal
note was so
um I think the time has come is just to
clean this up uh do something
appropriate with it get the unfunded
mandate out of there and let's let's
let's do this let's agree that there are
other unfunded mandates and let's make
it a passion of ours to get rid of all
of them you can do that one step at a
time this step is teed up for this
committee to just knock it out of the
park clean it up and then identify the
next one and we'll fix it too um that's
it if I'll take questions if there are
any any questions representative
wock Madam chair um see represent the
first question who is the administrator
you were quoting initially what school
uh the Auburn Village School and Auburn
in New Hampshire the principal was uh is
still uh Lori Collins uh she made the
request in the presence of the entire
School Board it was a a school board
meeting and I just could know what
school that was what was the grade level
on that school that is uh K through 8
okay may I follow my main question sure
thank you thank you for that information
um you made you made the statement that
that the purpose of that was like we
just I think you said stick a finger in
the eye of the New Hampshire
Constitution yes that's my perception of
why that sentence was crafted so
specifically that in only a tiny little
sentence both establish a mandate and
say we're not going to pay for it so
you're you're not I just want to be
clear on this you're not referring to
the intent of the
bill rather the funding of the bill want
to mix those two I'm I'm a finance guy
I'm a constitutional guy I I'm I'm
dealing and I'm also a healthcare guy so
the the the purpose of providing the
products is absolutely legit it's been
legit for as long as we've had girls
going to Public Schools the issue to me
is a constitutional one this is just a
clear violation that makes no sense for
us to leave it so obvious and a finance
one somebody's going to pay for it okay
I thank you I just just commentary I
just want to make sure we weren't
talking about the intent of the bill and
not rather the funding of the bill
I'm only talking about the funding okay
thank thanks much yes
sir any other questions I I just want to
say again because I've testified on a
similar Bill like this in the past and
it's like the opposition can't hear me
they keep pretending or or reacting to
the fact that I may be talking about the
product itself I'm not this is purely a
constitutional issue let's clean up the
language of the bill
any other
questions seeing none thank thank
you Devin Quinn
hi members of the committee my name is
Devin Quinn I'm from the New Hampshire
women's Foundation um we are opposed to
this bill um I want to start off with a
little bit of background I know that
representative Edwards just gave that
but I'll add a little bit more um I know
many of you have heard this before so um
bear with me for the record or for any
of you who are new um and then I want to
just go over for a couple of things and
um for those who couldn't be here who
I'm passing around letters I wanted to
pull out a one line or two but I'll try
to be as quick as
possible um this bill first came up in
2019 um it was the idea of um a young
woman in high school in Rochester
Caroline Dylan she worked with then
Senator Martha Hennessy uh to come up
with this bill um it was um a really uh
wonderful moment for New Hampshire it
was covered in a lot of um papers um
talking about Caroline's advocacy and
bravery to talk about um what is
considered a very stigmatized um uh
thing talking about ministration and
periods um it can feel stigmatized for
adults to talk about it so it's a really
big deal as you can imagine for a
student to come to hearings and talk to
legislators about it um when Governor
sonunu signed that bill in 2019 he said
this legislation is about equality and
dignity sb42 will help ensure young
women in New Hampshire Public Schools
will have the freedom to learn without
disruption and free of shame or fear of
stigma um since then about half of all
states have passed similar bills um
including Virginia in 2020 and Alabama
and Utah in
2022 um no states have repealed uh their
bill um and in a recent 2024 poll 77% of
people agree that menal products should
be supplied in in schools um as was
mentioned men over 1,400 people signed
in um in opposition to this bill which
is um notable for me I believe in a bill
like this um and I just wanted to go
over some of the issues we hear um every
year in attempts to repeal or water down
this bill um uh and particularly um from
students we've heard um last last B we
heard from Alex uh can um and you're
going to hear from Abby today so um this
is most meaningful when students show up
something they care about a lot um some
arguments that we have heard and you've
already heard of that it's too expensive
for schools I certainly understand that
um schools have a tough time paying for
everything that that certainly is um uh
I feel for schools trying to make it all
work um but I have a letter that I've
passed around here from um a retired
dean of students from pingr Academy
which for this um law public school um
Sue tardella says as a former New
Hampshire administrator I wish to
express my concerns regarding hb14 and
releasing public middle and high schools
from providing menstrual products in
girls and gender neutral bathrooms and
HB 415 presents a serious negative
consequences for young women in New
Hampshire schools um about the financial
burden she says State leaders supporting
415 argue that this provision places a
financial burden on school districts as
a former High School administrator
administrator I found the implementation
of the law to be seamless
I added the purchase of menal hygiene
products to my school's operating budget
along with toilet paper tissues hand
sanitizer Etc and menal products became
a routine part of the school's annual
supplies order continued support for the
law insures all students have equal
access to essential uh hygiene supplies
which can reduce miss school time while
improving overall well-being and
security um we've also heard in the past
um some ways to make um it optional um
or the words may but that is effectively
a repeat to be clear um and would be the
same as of course it was optional to do
before 2019 so it's effectively a repeal
um some folks have uh promoted a change
to uh offering it in School nurses um
offices um to cut down on cost and you
know my thinking is that if you're
cutting down on costs because it's in
School nurses um then that's because
they're giving out fewer products
because it's less accessible defeating
the purpose of it um specifically
another letter I gave to you all is from
uh the Executive Board of the New
Hampshire school Nurses Association uh
they are opposed to this bill uh and
they say prior to the law being passed
in 2019 many School nurses were already
placing hygiene products in bathrooms in
many schools we were pleased the 2019
law took action to spread the best best
practices to all schools um showing that
even the School nurses are showing that
the best practice is to have it where
students need it um
they also said teachers were pleased
that the implementation meant less
lessened Miss class time when menting
students head supplies closer to their
classroom as you can imagine this is
about school time and learning um and if
you can imagine being a girl in middle
school or high school and leaving math
class to go to the bathroom your teacher
expects you back in a few minutes time
but if you have to go to the
bathroom um need a uh mental product and
we all know that if you've uh had a PE
period you've been surprised by a period
in your life uh and if you have to then
go to the school nurse's office which is
um a place you have to publicly out loud
say what you need that's a good reason
not to go come back to your to the
bathroom then return back to class
that's a long amount of time you're
missing school this is interrupting
School instruction um and your teacher
might ask you why you've been gone so
long um these are really uncomfortable
things um that we can really avoid by
keeping this lot in place um lastly
there have been uh concerns about misuse
um students um uh you know playing with
these products or um shoving them in
toilets and the School nurses talk about
this as well um they say while the issue
of vandalism at first was an issue in
Middle Schools it did calm down
misbehavior in a bathroom is not a new
issue in middle schools for example if a
student clogs a toilet with paper towels
we do not take paper towels away we
address the behavior we've heard
multiple examples of if a student throws
food in a cafeteria do you take away
food for the whole school no uh it's not
a supply issue it's a behavior issue and
I feel for administrators and uh um
teachers trying to deal with all these
issues but this isn't a supply issue
um finally I just want to close with
another um voice of a student um who
could not be here her name is Hannah um
and she attended lonia High School from
2018 to 202 22 you have this letter as
well she says it's important to uh to
have accessible menal products in New
Hampshire middle and high schools
because it helps build a safe and
comfortable environment for students
having products in bathrooms makes it
easily available to everyone who needs
it without singling students out uh
while I know how to work to destigmatize
the conversation around periods and know
it's nothing to be ashamed of because
it's a natural bodily function middle
and high schoolers do feel ashamed of
needing menstrual products having to go
to the nurse can be uh embarrassing and
turn students away from asking for help
which only ends up harming them uh
females at any age should not be ashamed
of needing basic hygiene products um and
that's what we are taught from a young
age
um and menal products need to be
discussed and accessible to everyone so
I wanted to add her voice as well uh I'm
happy to take any questions any
questions representative cig thank you
so much um Miss Quinn I know that the
women's Foundation has done work looking
at poverty as it impacts um girls in
particular across the state what's the
impact of poverty on menring girls in
schools and how does that impact their
ability to be successful thanks for the
question so um we know that girls who or
young women who don't have access to
menual hygiene products um at home to
bring to school with them um they often
choose not to go to school they'll skip
school they'll skip class um that could
be days of school missed or um periods
of time um we know that not all students
have friends that they can ask for
products um this is about Miss class
time and um someone also at one point
said uh students might be stealing these
products and I would say that you you
can't steal something that's free um and
if you saw a student that was you know
taking a roll of toilet paper and
putting in his bag to go home you know
you wouldn't say he's stealing toilet
paper You' say wow what's going on at
home how come he doesn't have access to
toilet paper so really we're if anyone
is um needing menal products it's folks
who don't have access to bring them into
school themselves and also point out
this might seem obvious to um those of
you uh who have ever menstruated but for
those who haven't um products are very
different um there are just like toilet
paper or paper towels maybe at home you
buy a nicer type of paper towel or
toilet paper schools obviously are
buying the cheaper versions of that
they're also buying the cheaper versions
of menal products so um girls and young
women aren't preferring to use those
products if they have them on them they
want to use their own products this is
really about needing those products in
those bathrooms at that
moment thanks any other
questions seeing none thank you thanks
for your
time can't read
that
burns Abby
Burns I think
uh hello my name is Abigail banner and
I'm in seventh grade I go to a private
school and they do not provide menstrual
products in my school I cannot carry a
backpack or bag with me to my classes I
keep supplies I need in my locker which
is a long distance away from the
bathrooms there is no way easily get a
pad or tampon from my locker to the
bathroom without a
plan they aren't
provided in the bathroom like I said
before and my school monitors students
outside the class very
closely keeping track of the time you
spend outside of
class uh they have cameras outside the
bathrooms watching who goes in and who
comes out it would be more convenient if
they were already in there for me so I
had what I needed when I needed
them there was once this time when I had
to use the bathroom just to find out
that I started my
cycle I didn't have much time but I
thought through my options it was
getting close to the end of class so I
had about 3 minutes maximum to do
something on one hand I could go down
two flights of stairs to my locker grab
a pad go back upstairs and use it which
used more time than I had or I could use
toilet paper and wait until lunch which
was next block I chose the
ladder after class was dismissed I went
back to my locker I snuck a pad into my
skirt pocket and made it beine for the
cafeteria bathrooms it was a stressful
moment and not the first time I'd use a
substitute for a
pad my school doesn't have a full-time
nurse our equivalent is the front desk
which has its own specific pass and is
located in a different section of the
school building making it a hassle to go
to
I could ask my friends for help but
since there's so much taboo and shame
when it comes to talking about periods
openly it would require a well an entire
wellth thought out plan to not get
caught by a suspicious
teacher the repeal of this bill might
not affect me the same way as my public
school peers but I do know what it would
be like for
them thank you any
questions seeing none thank oh oh thank
you so much for coming forward and
speaking
thank oh representative Freeman no no
I'm Oh I thought you did okay
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the House Education policy and
administration committee I hope I do as
good a job as the last person did that
was great um so as you know my name is
Sharon McCarthy and for five years I've
been the CEO of Girls Inc New Hampshire
um prior to that for over 20 years I was
the publisher of New Hampshire Business
review and New Hampshire magazine I'm
the mother of two teenagers I live in
Bedford New
Hampshire Girls Inc um just for some
background um is a Girls Leadership
organization that's been serving New
Hampshire girls ages 5 to 18 for over 50
years our mission is to inspire all
girls to be strong smart and bold
through education healthy living and
self-esteem we're one of the largest of
75 Affiliates around the country and we
have two centers one in Manchester and
one in nsha and we also have Outreach
programs in over 20 schools all around
the state of New Hampshire
our research-based programming that
we're known for includes stem financial
literacy leadership mental health um and
many other programs um that are arranged
by age of the girls the majority of the
girls we serve in our centers are very
lwi income and the majority are single
parent
households I'm here today to testify an
opposition to House Bill 415 which would
remove requirements that schools provide
menstrual products as you
know period poverty impacts many of the
girls and families that we serve we have
a partnership with United Way of Greater
NASA whereby we have a period Pantry
known as Rosy's Pantry in our NASA
Center that supplies free feminine
products to our girls their families and
to the
community we restock this Pantry daily
it's actually um something that our
older girls enjoy doing it's it we go
through many products every single day
um that they use and many other people
um it's often a matter of not being able
to afford these products it costs on
average I just looked online from
Walmart to other places it's um8 to2 per
box of tampons or pads so it's expensive
especially with a family that has
several
girls this impacts a girl's emotional
well-being to not be able to afford
these products and it does impact their
education many girls especially the
younger girls as was mentioned are just
too embarrassed to head to the school
nurse and they're mortified if they have
an accident at school that's happened to
my daughters it's happened to me I'm
sure it's happened to almost every
female in this room having products
available at no charge in school
bathrooms can help ease this hardship
for New Hampshire girls especially lower
income girls and all girls who might not
have the products they need at that time
based on Girls Inc National research one
in four teens have missed class time due
to lack of access to menstrual hygiene
products and our goal is to try to keep
kids in the classroom one in five teens
have struggled to afford period products
or have not been able to purchase them
at all and in 2019 when Governor suu
signed Senate Bill
142 requiring schools to provide these
free products
um it was mentioned earlier but the goal
was to achieve equality and
dignity House Bill 4115 would reverse
that goal so on behalf of Girls Inc of
New Hampshire we respectfully ask the
committee to consider voting inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 415 in order
to continue to provide the girls of the
state with the access to free menstrual
hygiene products that they may urgently
need to get through their school day
thank you and I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative drive thank you and thank
you for taking my question U if this is
going on now where it's mandated but not
funded by the state but it is a
successful
product why does it need a law to keep
going wouldn't schools if it wasn't a
law wouldn't many schools just opt to no
longer do it and then have the risk of
girls needing products not having them
and then not going to
school I I hope I'm understanding your
question properly thank you I think
we're we're understand each other
slightly um but I guess my question is
they are doing it now they're not being
funded why would they not do it when
they're not being funded and there's no
law I think they've realized maybe we've
how good it is absolutely yes why not
just continue the way that we're going
exactly
but without having an unfunded mandate
behind it it seems like something that's
been in place for quite some time and is
uh I think it's been an accepted policy
with probably very few exceptions in
schools because it's a needed way for
girls to be able to get through the day
if they need those products I I I do not
have the cost of what it is for a school
but I can't imagine that it is blowing
away their expense
line representative muray thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question I forgive me and it may not
have been you but wasn't there just
testimony regarding the fact that um
supplies just like many other school
supplies was worked into an operating
budget um in many times and so they are
funded to some in some instances through
the school through the individual
schools my understanding is that it is a
it's a line item in ex existing schools
and that's been in place thank you
representative Freeman thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I I'm very familiar with Girls
Inc um I lived in Manchester for 27
years and was on the school board for
four so I do know the great work that it
does um but do you know if um the
Manchester the Nashville School District
would stop supplying this product these
products with the passage of this bill
do you have any inside information on
that I do not know the answer to that
question
um May I Madam chair I I also wanted to
um this is more of a statement than a
question but I do know that Manchester
has independently been supplying those
items for years without any state
intervention I'm not sure about nashaa
um so I I tend to believe that
Manchester would definitely not stop
supplying um those products to those
those girls with the passage of this
bill so um you know if you do know that
Manchester and Ash is going to stop
giving those giving those products out
to the girls because of the passages
this bill I think you should alert this
committee thank you thank you
representative cig thank you so much and
thank you for taking my question um I
know your organization works with um
younger girls as well and um it's my
understanding and you may not be the one
who is the answer to this um but is that
we're seeing um an increase in girls
beginning to menstrate much younger than
um you know even my 11-year-old self was
um which means that we're now seeing
needs for these products even in
elementary schools for like third
graders and fourth graders um and so I'm
I'm curious if you have any information
about that and then also along with that
I'm also thinking about a girl who might
have a a single father or maybe multiple
fathers in their home but not uh a
female figure that they can reach out to
at the onset of their men's
and and the impact of that and so I just
wonder if you might have any insight as
to either of those I feel like I can
comment on that I I'm not sure I have
statistics that might support what I'm
saying I can tell you what I see um so
many girls start their period at Girls
Inc and and so many of them are very
very young and um we tend to be the
people they talk to about that uh we
send them home with supplies we give
them supplies when they need them and um
we certainly have single fathers in our
better the single parent of girls in our
program and we also have girls that are
in households with rapidly changing role
models in their home um so it's very
important that we play the role we do
with them starting their period And I
think schools with the goal of keeping
kids in class and girls will not go to
school if they do if they have a heavy
period and don't don't have supplies
period they just no pun intended they
they stay
home and um so to comment on your
question uh yes many girls are starting
earlier and need supplies and we Supply
them and schools supplying them only
makes sense thank you so
much any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you uh Rachel
good afternoon Madame chair and members
of the committee uh my name is Rachel
Glansberg I'm a student over at
Dartmouth and I serve on the youth
advisory Council of the organization
period and briefly I just wanted to
share an additional student perspective
as to just how important it is to uphold
this bill um menal products are just as
essential as toilet paper so and paper
towels in school restrooms menstruation
is a natural biological process
experienced by more than half the
population for a significant portion of
their lives denying access to these
products stigmatizes menstruation and
perpetuates gender inequality now when I
was in high school just a few short
months ago I saw firsthand how the lack
of access to Metal Products impacted my
peers many students had to leave class
to search for a product often feeling
embarrassed or ashamed to ask for help
some even miss school entirely because
their parents their families simply
couldn't afford these basic necessities
witnessing this inequity motivated me to
take action and back in New Jersey I
worked with my school administration and
student groups to ensure that menual
products were freely available in our
restrooms this initiative not only
reduced the stigma surrounding periods
but also created a more supportive
environment where students could focus
on learning instead of worrying about
their next pad or tampon now inspired by
the impact this project had within my
own school I advocated for New Jersey's
version of this bill bill S1 1221 which
provided free menal products in our
restrooms and the positive impact of
this program was absolutely undeniable
attendance improved and students
expressed relief and gratitude for
having one less barrier to their
education this experience is why I feel
so strongly that every student deserves
access to menstral products in their
school restrooms in speaking with the
students of hampsh New Hampshire I know
that RSA 18916 a is similarly critical
in allowing students to thrive in and
out of the classroom again period
poverty affects one in four students
Nationwide a figure that is worsened due
to the covid-19 pandemic according to
the 2023 restated the period study by
period and thanks nearly 23% of
menstrating students have struggled to
afford menstrual products this lack of
access had significant consequences for
students many Miss class time or even
entire school days because they don't
have the resources to manage their
periods these absences hinder academic
performance and increase the risk of
long-term social and EM social and
economic disadvantages without access to
proper products students May resort to
unsafe Alternatives or use products for
longer than recommended which increases
their risk of infections and other
health complications furthermore the
stigma and embarrassment associated with
lacking menstrual products takes a heavy
emotional D leading to feelings of Shame
anxiety and isolation repealing RSA
18916 a would send a message that
menstrating students needs are secondary
exacerbating period poverty and
educational disparities it would Place
undue burdens on students and their
families forcing some to choose between
attending school and managing their
periods again any bill that prioritizes
the health dignity and education of all
students is of the utmost importance so
any changes amendments whatever it needs
that need to be made most important
thing of all is that we're getting these
students the dignity they deserve that's
all thank
you thank you any questions
representative sell super quickly thank
you so much for your testimony could you
just email that to the committee
absolutely we'll
do any other questions no thank you
thank
you um Mike
are you going to try
I wait what is
it not a problem Mike appleberg with
United
Way b b bad handwriting at all um I'm
the president of the United Way of
Greater Nashua and um she had to leave I
see but I wanted to also just
acknowledge Abigail for coming and
giving testimony today I think that was
pretty wonderful to see a young person
doing that
um in a just a sidebar representative C
you asked a question about the age of
menstrating students we know I know
personally from experience of talking
with student with School nurses in the
nashaa school district that they're um
typically seeing third and fourth
graders at this point so even though
this law only applies to middle school
and high school level um gosh don't we
wish it was actually expanded to include
all uh all School levels and was going
in the other direction
altogether um just a couple of
additional points that haven't been made
we I've come up with a list of five
different points for why we believe that
it's important to oppose HB 415 um first
of all basic needs should never be a
barrier to success menstrual hygiene
products are essential for students to
feel confident and prepared during the
school day without access to these items
students feel unnecessary challenges
that are infer with their ability to
focus on their learning I'm gonna say
personally I have a daughter who happens
to be a guidance counselor in one of
NASA's middle schools and so we have
interesting conversations around the
dinner table as you might imagine which
include all manner of student Behavior
what one of those is that she will
absolutely acknowledge that she has do
CH children girls who will not come to
school because they are having their
period or they're surprised by their
period or they do not have access to the
products because they can't afford them
one point that has not been made yet yet
today is that these products are not
covered by any of the social safety net
programs like like food food stamps or
um you know U Wick so these are
out-of-pocket expenses that have to be
born by the families and are quite
expensive uring fairness for all
students current law ensures that no
student is at disadvantage because of
their financial circumstances removing
this requirement with disproportionately
affect those who are already struggling
that creates an uneven playing field in
our schools I think that's something we
would all College we do not want um
supporting health and wellness the um
the speaker Abigail mentioned uh making
some unhealthy unsafe decisions about
using um toilet paper in Le of a pad um
when students lack access to menstrual
products they may resort to unsafe
Alternatives or prolong the use of a
single product which can lead to health
issues such as infections I think uh
we're all are aware of that this law
ensures that students can manage their
personal health needs without um safely
without dignity and without stigma and
um you know lastly I would say the cost
has been brought up several times I
think the uh representative Edwards
stated that the reason for this
particular legislation is to get rid of
an unfunded mandate um I think the
funding involved is really you know
fairly minimal in the large scheme of
things and um especially when you
compare to the benefits of improved
attendance participation overall
well-being so we at United way would
absolutely encourage you to vote this
inexpedient to legislate and to support
the current current law and I'll I have
written testimony that I'll share with
you but I'll also take any questions if
you might have any thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you for your time I really appreciate
it is there anyone else looking to
testify on this
bill okay we're going to close the heing
on HB
4155 we'll have to take a little bit of
a break so we can find our missing
member before we start
exec
e
e e
start our exec
session
yeah that's I want to get
[Laughter]
okay I think we have a couple of bills
we want to take care of this
afternoon um the first um we'll take a
look at is HB 116 relative to reporting
requirements for
publicy and uh representative Freeman
did you have a a motion U yes Mr
chairman I'd like to make the motion of
in expedient to
legislate second second by
representative
Terry uh any
discussion representative
Hall yes um I just want to make
reference to I agree with the motion
actually um and I would like make
reference to Cole Brown we only heard
from Pinkerton that day um and Cole
Brown I spoke with them yesterday they
sent us this letter and basically saying
you know what we don't get any state
funding no adequacy funding no special
ed funding no CTE funding no building
Aid they asked for a grant the doe said
no and
so it just doesn't make sense that the
um that they would be held to
this thank you thank you any further uh
comments from anybody on the committee
I see none oh yes I'm sorry
representative s thank you I I think I
would say to if if the members of um the
school districts that are involved with
these Publicis are listening and
following our our hearing today I would
just encourage them if they are having
complications there's they should
certainly band together and go together
to talk about their contracts together
with the provider school and figure out
a way to work things out in a way that's
Equitable and fair for all of them right
yes I think I would agree that uh it
sounds like it's a a solution that uh is
probably workable uh ifone sits down
together um I think format uh is
something that uh we've taken care of
for uh quite a number of decades um so I
I think uh I think it's a solvable
problem without uh State legislation at
this point representative Hall thank you
Mr chair and just to follow up Co Brown
did say say with their towns that send
all those kids their contract stipulates
on what what information they get and
it's a perfectly well oiled machine so
um works for them thank
you anything
further uh seen nothing um Madam clerk
could you take the
role Vice chairman Noble yes
representative Terry yes representative
dry yes repres representative Freeman
yes representative litfield yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes
yes representative
Hall good yes representative Bon yes yes
representative
yes representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass
yes chairman cordelli
yes 17 Y no Nays one non
voting great consent okay with everybody
for that yes great um so so yeah we just
want to check off
that so the next one um we'll take a
look at is sorry Mr chairman did I was
I'm not paying attention did you ask for
it to be okay to people yes thank
you it's okay with you right
[Laughter]
okay um yeah since you voted for it yes
um uh next is hp93 enabling school
districts to appoint a school district
Treasurer uh representative
Lichfield yes um chair cordelli I would
like to open the discussion but I would
like to please add an amendment with a
motion of a to passes
amended okay so um so the motion on the
floor is ought to pass and you want to
have an amendment that you're passing
around correct yes is there yeah is
second to the ought to pass
representative
Terry um obviously you're going to read
it but should I can I share now or you
want me to wait uh wait one minute okay
you don't have to
a I think everyone has it um
representative if you want to go over
the amendment thank you so the bill is
brought forward with simply enabling
legislation where right now now the
school district Treasurer is elected and
we had received feedback that maybe
sometimes folks did not have all the
qualifications necessary for that
position this amendment that I'm putting
forward is just to set the bar a little
bit higher um when we go and this
warrant article is brought forward to
change the position from an elected
position to an appointed position I just
want to make sure that the voters um are
informed of the gravity of the decision
and just change it to a 3 F vote in
other words 60% if the voters should
decide to undo this at some point and
they would like to see this position
elected again versus appointed uh they
just need a simple majority to do
that uh thank you um
and
um is there a second to her Amendment on
the amendment her motion on the
amendment represent Morris one second
thank thank you
um
representative
yes so as it stands right now the school
districts elect um they'll elect their
Treasurer right if they don't have
someone um that's on the ballot or if
the person leaves then they appoint them
so the legislation that was brought
forward was to put a warrant article
forward if a town so desires instead of
having the treasurer elected then the
Treasurer would be appointed from then
on um I just don't necessarily agree
with taking away that right from the
voters they currently can vote on it so
my feeling was what if we compromise and
we just set the bar a little bit higher
we're still just enabling legislation
and we're saying to the towns yes you
may vote you know you may vote to change
this and appoint the treasurer but it's
a 60% bar to change that that's all
repres Woodcock thank you Mr
chair question I may um any other ballot
on the warrant
article does that uh that's on an
article for normal uh spring warrant
does does it have a 60% requirement or
just have a
majority I was going to say off the top
my head I only know bonds I'm not sure
about other things I me May is sure I'm
is this a rhetorical question represent
we've created no I'm just concern we
created a a bar everywhere else we use
50% for election 51 or what whatever the
game is but 60% is a heck of a number
pretty restrictive I just wonder why it
wouldn't just be leave it as it is a
majority
vote so that's all just speaking for me
um it just makes me very uncomfortable
to take a position that is elected and I
feel as though we're almost taking away
that sa from the voters and we're going
to make it an appointed position so I
just I just felt that this is fair thank
you thank you Mr
chair uh represent
M thank you Mr chair um thank you for
taking my question I I guess one one
part that I want to make sure I'm
understanding with respect to the
amendment of
043 um the two changes that I see
actually are the change of uh to a three
fth
requirement uh on the warrant article to
pass and then the other one was a change
in language on line 8 from the original
Bill HB 93 to the amendment where it
then also adds by a simple majority is
that
correct yes so to undo it it's a simple
majority to move the other direction
it's three fths
yes yes representative Cornell I'm not
all that familiar with warrant articles
in Manchester we don't have them so I is
that three fifths of people voting on
that day or three- fifths of the entire
eligible to
vote whoever shows up thank
you yes sure and then and then just a
simple majority of The District board or
is that I I I'm still wanting to make
sure I'm
understanding
line8 so it's the is it the board or is
it the voters I'm sorry it's the
voters on line
eight it says any school district
it's that way in the original
also that's how it was
originally um well how did it pass must
I'm sorry there a
question okay I did ask a question just
I wanted to make sure that I was clearly
one is a vote by The District board and
one is by the voters at large under
warrant I don't see a board on all I see
is school
district be made inance with rs76 by the
school
board right um one thing I just noticed
um and it's the same way in the original
in the original it's online
um no okay that's that's okay
there no I I I guess it's okay um I'm
reading it a second time and I corrected
myself to rec the
appointment when it goes right yeah Mr
chairman it's it it at least seems that
it's unclear as to the meaning and I I
think it needs a little more work to be
clear about the intent what what do we
mean here do we mean any the voters of a
school district do we mean the do we
mean the school board we have to know
what we mean rather than leave it vague
right I'm not sure uh I'm on the line
eight uh to the
amendment line eight says any school
district May resend a vote what does
that
mean what's a school district just
curious though this is in the I don't
disagree with you but it's it's in the
original Bill too we just carried it
over line8 then we may have missed it in
the original Bill do you have the
original bill yeah I do
okay yeah on line8 and the original
bill it says it
says yes it you carried the L excuse me
the language was carried over but I'm
noticing that it it's vague in the bill
as well so you've done a a service here
at the very least with the amendment by
pointing out to us that we've got vager
that needs to be clarified right school
school warn
articles they now
now is on their own side
see
yes I I wonder where we're trying to
figure out the intricacies of the
language and the specificity if it might
be best to recess the executive hearing
on this till m when we're executing
other bills so that there's an
opportunity to um for whoever wants to
work on the amendment to get the
language clarified so that we
can make sure we're voting on a
something we all understand
um that's diplomatic yeah I I I would
just look I'm just looking at
1973 um which is raising money at a
special meeting um no School District at
a special meeting shall rais your
appropriate money I think it's pretty
clear they're talking about the voters
in that school district not the School
District board I I think probably the
same you know applies
here Mr chair yes it is it possible to
ask if Miss Wilson from the school
boards Association no
sure also you have attorney of back
Jen good afternoon sorry I'm still
getting used to
this uh for the record Becky Wilson from
the New Hampshire school boards
Association I Are there specific
questions I will give you my two second
uh assessment of this which is and I did
just double check with bar Christina uh
the majority of warrants are simple
majority unless they involve finances or
Bonds in which case they're 60%
right and um there was a question about
the language any school district um my
understanding is that that would mean
the voters of the school
district uh thank you for the question I
I think if there's question about the
interpretation of that language it may
make sense to try to clarify what is
actually intended with that a school
district is not necessarily a voting
body I the the members of the town that
make up the school district would be the
voters of the district as opposed to the
school district which is its own entity
per se I just I it may it may make sense
to try to clarify what the intention of
that language really is yeah um in the
original bill um if we look at section
two um the only amendment is the
addition of an RSA but the uh current
statutory language says at each School
district election each School District
which is not a Cooperative uh shall
elect uh again I think clearly talking
about the voters in that school district
same same in the first line the school
district
yeah
right does representative Hall thank you
Mr I just have a question so the first
sentence um says any school district
which is not a Cooperative School
District so it defines that so now skip
down to line8 when it just says any
school district is it an assumption that
we referring back to sentence number one
in a case like that it now doesn't say
which is not a Cooperative school
district is that a problem or is that
just understood to be I I don't see it
as a problem you don't see it no does
anyone see it as a problem thank
you what can I would
may I be excused yes you may I'm
sorry I wish we could be excused
too I just I just I'm sorry Mr chair I
just wonder if we could perhaps get a a
definitive answer from one of the
attorneys about whether we need to make
that language more specific I would hate
for us to expend the time voting on this
only to get it sent back and have to
have more hearings because we could have
changed a word or added a word for
clarification that we might not have
realized and if we can just get that
corrected or specified maybe we could
avoid extra time later um okay you want
your your sugges we hold this all over
until next week so so that those
involved in writing the amendment can
verify the language with an attorney and
make sure we've got the exact language
we need
okay yes represent I'm just looking at
the any looking at the any school
district may send a vote part and it has
to be a not a Cooperative School
District because they couldn't have
gotten to the place where they had
appointed a School treasurer if they
hadn't been a school district which is
not a
Cooperative
yes thank you Mr chair so
we just heard from Miss Wilson that they
only do that um for finances and bonds
is that an issue I mean are we concerned
about
that right that's what I'm saying I mean
do we want do we think it should go back
to majority if that's a if you only do
it for finances and bonds the treasurer
does the finances he does but I don't
think that's what it means is it do you
think I I don't I'm not sure if that's
statute anywhere yes yes I was going to
ask although it may not
be it may not have ever been before is
it prohibited from being by Statute so
that hypothetically if we were to say 3
fifths we would not be running a muck or
a foul of an existing statute with
respect to uh warrant articles that
requires that it only be a simple
majority and not anymore I don't know
the answer to that question right um s
yeah
Woodcock just a question to the chair is
it possible that alls could give us an
opinion on this um laal staff there I
think since a number of people have
questions about a couple of aspects um
we can hold it over until next week and
do
some yeah thank you
yeah is everybody okay with
that representative
litfield okay
um that leaves
um HB
184 establishing a committee to study
changing school start
times
um I think um a number of us had
questions about some of the language um
in the bill um and especially um the uh
duties uh section for the uh study
committee um which uh
seems to indicate that um it's uh
looking clearly for uh
legislation um out of the study
committee um so uh I think that uh our
preference would be to uh hold this over
also so we could uh do some uh looking
at that language that came up a couple
of times during the
hearing
um and um you know we'll have some
people um work on uh um what the
committee shall actually
do is that representative Bon um they're
also the composition of the committee um
I think was uh limited to just
legislators and if you are going to put
together a committee that studies such a
broad issue it might be need to be more
inclusive so I don't know if that's one
of the things we could talk about
yeah res thank you Mr shair I just point
of Border I just want to make sure that
that is the difference would be a
commission if we're adding stakeholders
and a committee if it's just legislative
members correct okay right um yeah I I
think that uh uh I would prefer to see
it stay as a study committee it gives us
a little bit more flexibility uh
commission it's going to be hard to uh
uh round up every PE everybody and have
this done by November 1st of this year
um and and uh I know that uh there is uh
quite a backlog in trying to get uh
people um assigned to either a study
committee or a um a commission so I
think that uh we'll have a better chance
um if we keep this as a committee and
invite people in uh to provide input um
and you know we heard that a number of
groups um who had looked at this um had
uh access to studies and so forth
already um so uh I think we can um move
it uh fairly quickly um and make that
November 1st date um once we get it uh
passed so if it's all right we'll hold
um uh these two until uh next week and
um
we I don't think we need to make a
motion no
um we have uh two days next week a
Monday and
Wednesday um Monday will start at 10:
9:30 on uh
Wednesday um there'll be a fairly fairly
full days um and there'll be notation in
the calendar for each that um time
permitting we can exact bills um
previously heard so uh you know we'll
just uh see which say we can fit them in
um and when we have uh language ready
from uh uh
os does that sound good with
everybody um yeah we'll talk about that
yeah great anything
uh huh yeah right yeah and uh yeah how
could I forget we're back here
tomorrow right um yes n :30 tomorrow um
another uh full day 10 tomorrow oh is it
10 tomorrow yes right I'm sorry just a
reminder 10 o'
tomorrow yes just a reminder we can stop
by tomorrow downstairs to get your
photos taken for your IDs between 8 and
9:30
okay thank you very
much have a good evening
that works because I told Alexander
thought we were holding it over till
next week
anyway for